see the button all right waiting for you
two to cooperate oh wow that was fast
alright and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 131 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guest and
we've got out of worlds and Call of Duty
impressions last of us to delayed PS 5
the fastest console and fallout 76 to
discuss so we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who I had
the pleasure of connecting with through
mutual friend of the Rome
Lord mods gaming not only is this not a
kind of score when it comes to the
analysis of next-gen hardware but he is
also a fellow og gamer with the console
resume to prove it
introducing the creating host of the
Mojo Blues YouTube channel and panelist
of the next gen podcast the horror movie
enthusiasts and still the Lord of CRT
and laserdisc laugh from Tennessee by
way of Germany and making his debut into
the realm of the Lords mom made Lord
mojo blues how you doing sir
absolute pleasure to have you in the
room we were talking for a little bit
Vance finally get this thing done man
for WoW almost since the first day you
guys been on I've been watching and I've
always like yeah I need to be on that
show yeah for whatever reason I never
got around a synonym or anything but
eventually I did the rest is history we
had that uh demise I think first off had
the podcast the next Jebb probably talk
about a Playstation 5 hardware the next
gen stuff and that's what he got a
chance to link up so I said you don't
going to it cogs will keep his word dude
no but everything what you've been
playing man no no call of duty I'm not
just in the first person and once I
heard that
campaign was only about five hours
mm-hmm yeah I'll get it eventually just
to play that but for now it's it's all
outer worlds whoo no doubt basically up
until I started on that one now
yesterday I played anything every movie
Josie Wow well we go get to it I would
call myself a big RPG I don't like a
hundred hour 50 hour games but this is
about the right link and it's got that
humor I might be playing it all the way
up till the Star Wars game comes out we
get to say those thoughts mojo we got to
hold discuss it for that women we're
good to have you around brother man
definitely a pleasure man let's get to
it so you already know we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming don'ts original Lords
in a room here at the round table
my co-host with Cole most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror Lord of review
and the half of the three in the morning
before we move on from you to my boy cat
daddy fat stacks look too cold it not a
super chat
our world is awesome I've never
experienced a game that cost me less
than a cheeseburger there's been some
good Thank You Phil PC and game pass so
uh it's been just that it's been just a
game past biscuit for you or addict
that's what it's been it's not a game
it's a Sony biscuit right oh my god
shout out to dizzy very early with the
slander $2 hooch at these King old soft
knees avoiding the delivery your head
goes spin you're gonna be really dizzy
know that PlayStation 5 launches and of
course returning we have around the
realm the most technical gaming Lord who
left me alone on a switch topic last
week where we gonna get back
who abandon me for abuse we go get back
to you Joe gave us listen to the sick of
playing Selfridge experience and also
the Sascha Thomas mr. offline profile
Illuminati and lower patron of the iron
bake my man Lord sovereign are you doing
sir doing well doing well good morning
[Music]
we both said it mm-hmm
if that X cloud is what it is my brother
the switches into bushes and wall so and
we've always run it we've always your
joining the dirty beard I said it but
the thing is I know for cog even more
because he's less of a Nintendo head him
even the Nintendo stuff I don't think
will draw him back in so if that like I
said I thought is what it is I think
Nintendo might be the bushes apologies
for missing last week it could not be
avoided uh so they acknowledge what you
do in life that you okay it wasn't it
wasn't life that I that I cared to do
tube wrap into Lord
boom and endorse move for coming through
a hole downtown it was funny like last
Saturday so after my my Yanks took that
epic Elvis I was like should I go to bed
or should I just you know I needed to
expel some energy that's in the remake
years like four o'clock in the morning
right I'll get up like you know 10
whatever be ready for the show
mm-hmm coming about 5:45 a.m. I get a
phone call saying oh um yeah Brian like
a a pipe exploded
no you two you need to go so I text car
get about that time like I'm done I
gotta go handle this I doubt I'll be
back and I think it's like 9 10 o'clock
no no you said yeah I have never seen
mm-hmm
that much water in places where it did
not belong I got back in the house again
apologies just happy to have you back
just don't ever pick a switch topic and
leave me alone you know in honest saw I
got a hold a dead man the goons came out
the foodies cave outside they was out it
was like you ain't got your menu by they
caught me laughing they're like it was
straight [ __ ] abuse Bobby it was all
fire it was all fire it was got this
they got I got when you bro and I saw
who you brought us at all know
you know you got it you got it for the
outer world gosh we'll get to it
Christopher has everything lit and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer ooh the Lord of
combat sports king of the statues who
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement ooh
beloved Lord King how you doing sir I'm
doing fantastic first and foremost I'm
gonna give a shout out to my boy kid
smooth Oh take the one ship challenge no
reason
Oh No wait on you to be doing that
challenge six degrees of separation all
in one power it was something to behold
and I wanna give a shout out to him
again another video that I must put in
my save archive oh shut up
Christopher Hart yes true is that true
let's just call it what it is babies
bigger boobs continue kick-start the
Christopher Hart for the bending of the
knee sir I saw you going in you was
holding your own for a minute dear boy
but those dudes is a my twitter did you
know a couple of things about you know
game pass this week and on friday doubt
of oils coming out in playstation had to
pay go play best over here oh boy he did
not know
these dudes are ravaging and they were
going at him like wild dogs so you know
you need it was gonna loaf and my man
had to go low to Chris never lower
yourself to those dudes let him stay as
low as they want to go but just just
keep your head up high brother
so you when he finally broke it I don't
care go play with up y'all wanna play go
be with your family I'm out I had to say
my Manson was like it was I swear oh you
said your goons he said one thing I
swear one his defense and these dudes
just was real but he was a good sport to
go to that teespring store mm-hmm how
many bushes is out all right Dom in the
bushes and also in the back for the IOP
love is on the back you get your little
badge of honor right there you when
you're walking you know the real Hat you
supposed to write you sort of joint that
you see the real you see you see what it
is we got that we also got the truck
[Laughter]
you keep trying to get me Atticus I was
able to read those chats um somebody
eggs for the Hulk right hook is dead
know what I'm trying to figure out is if
all y'all acts for the whole thing
you'll see the juggernaut right there
and all y'all acts for the Hulk how come
y'all not giving the same amount of love
that you gave the juggernaut
uses up to what what 300 some trade yeah
Oh up that way I mean to meet I'm a hawk
fan he's a better statue watch the video
I agree I'm with you on that
that's what service a little to the cake
you should be playing anything to get a
chance to touch anything
captain game passes in the building shut
up the game pass forgiven me that Lego
world you know me and my son was getting
nice and that that was legit the ukulele
that I didn't have to pay a nickel for
mr. Joe kazooie loved that was so much
fun so really this month I got my 1495
worth just those two games but the
people in this world what would that be
cake this is inside the bush certified
banging yes my kid ukulele you can play
with your kitty you can play by yourself
and then outer world you know listen
just like mojo Sam the humor the joke
that ever
thing that you're playing in that game
shout out to dad game is so much fun
this summer I know me and addict on
going on some things that we don't like
about it
um later but it's trust me just just go
get your game pass go get out there if
you don't have an Xbox go pick up an
Xbox let's get those numbers up let's go
let's go I had no doubt and of course
you already know we got to learn to
cooperate experience and gaming ninja
himself Laura kognito spreading that
realness in the realm of the IOP not
tell me what you want to hear but what
you need to hear so yeah man it's been
the shadow creep grind I gotta finish
getting my Leviathan its breath I know
you guys running around with that bow
acting up I got to get that joint done
and yeah man it's been out of worlds
that do that German game paths of course
and um yeah man been rocking we'll
definitely have a lot to say on that
just want to say a couple things I'm
real quick
first of all around please please send
your love man hey take this brother up
Italian clowns man he's going through it
man may have a procedure a serious
procedure about the heart so um please
reach out to our brother that's our
toys-r-us brethren you know what I'm
saying man for guys with quarter crew
mate you know I mean so please reach out
to him send him your best wishes you put
the thoughts while he goes through what
he needs to go through um other than
that man those two games probably
primarily and then um oh ok solve you
have seen this weekend oh my god so I
forgot that it was early right uh-huh
listen man this is what happens when you
move up to the major ladies your suspect
WC sub par mid to your opponents talk
about it when you face one of the
greatest grapplers to ever put in the
Octagon one of the best fighters to
never win a title mm-hmm you're probably
gonna get it and then Askren got it oh
yeah losing streak we've got yoked out
the way only Demian Maia key
tacular transition and really it didn't
it didn't happen earlier because my
wanting to stand with him mm-hmm
only reason it didn't happen earlier no
shuttle shot the punch up our Lord
easily in the chavín see that David
about some guy right there oh yeah man
so um technically we can make the
argument that Ben Askren could
potentially be Owen three if you counted
the first we know we beat Lola but you
don't say like it was under
controversial right yeah shout out to a
set up to the replica was her yeah it
was her being it was one arm yeah man I
had this discussion with a couple of
people I ain't gonna lie gonna expose
them but they were like you know talking
a lot of you know you know I don't see
how my is gonna win and I just said look
the area that this guy is good at Maya
is an expert at so yeah you know so the
wrestling versus BJJ thing I was just
like okay I just didn't feel I felt like
my improved stand-up why so I don't know
if he's necessarily wanted man yes I was
like that's not it almost King it almost
felt like data was onto something
[Music]
what he's certain is dude up right he's
not allowing him to get his bearings and
he stepped into the UFC and he has been
putting the Wolves on his neck from day
one I didn't really think that he was
gonna beat him I said let me just see
the fight and when he was all over him
like a cheap suit it was nice when they
were standing up it was cute and then
when it got to that floor things just
started to look really different and I
thought Ben was I thought that was his
strength to be honest with you I thought
that he was gonna get on the floor and
then he was gonna grind him out like he
didn't work like that
not my ax man listen Ben actually got
the first takedown right to the ground
okay cool but then he did he did what he
tries to do which is to grind you out
tire you out
myah myah basically could have laid down
and said yeah come on yeah this is where
I belong like wants to be like you just
don't want to put you don't want to play
with a snake don't wanna do in the state
garden you know
you shout out to him but yeah it's
looking really spooky for Ben right now
you know you just five-second lead you
to win from that's it
that's my question there like where does
he get a win from because to be honest
with you I didn't really think he um he
be there being honest with good oh where
does his win come from his drooly real
win his only win would come from taking
down a striker striker Pierce really
immediately without cuz I I give it to
him he has heart he can take a beating
mm-hmm usually after you get knocked out
the way got knocked out Chin's never the
same you know I don't think you can take
beatings like that anymore before going
out it's not happening so he needs to
take somebody down that is not
proficient on the ground immediately and
and win a fight that way no though shout
out the duty with a tool a super chat
it's on next week's card or who's next
week I forgot oh do your self a favor
since we're talking about subscription
services I don't normally pump other
people's subscription services like a
fight fan and you want to see that fight
coming up next week with um Kovalev
versus Canelo take your phone download
the zone go to your game store just you
know sign up for the month of whatever
dropping right after you watch the fight
those are one of those fights
it's 49.95 in the store you know just
you know download the zone watching UFC
it has an app of that nature also coming
to so when that app goes live you can
watch fights directly from your phone
you can watch all types of matches and I
think is um is a great idea with these
services you can pick stuff how you want
it this week is gonna be real that's
what we got on the UFC and everything
with gaming with me but uh yeah man we
gonna get into it now we gotta what the
Lords have been playing I want to start
with Lord mojo
his video game system history his
journey as a new content creator and of
course what led him to the amazing next
gen podcast as well as his own beat exp
so Lord mojo let's stuff in a very
beginner man or some of the first video
game systems you had and what
Gina gave me some moves around 74c fire
let's get it
my mom brought home she worked at Sears
in the catalog department oh that's
wrong basically a Sears pong machine
Estella game I was calling her
neighborhood
she's so regretted doing it what's she
doing she didn't realize that there was
gonna be 30 kids in the house they talk
about all this no it was only
revolutionary the very first time when
you could actually play games on your TV
facts and it was incredible I was about
probably let's go 12 13 skip that og
took going that's right a couple years
later she brought home another share
Estella game system but this one was
just a rebadged 2600 ok with grain and
all it was sweet but it's interstellar
games on the front but he was in the
state rebadged 2600 he played all the
cartridges mm-hmm so I finished out
pretty much the 70s just uh you know
jamming with those games which quality
wise yeah about 80 I was graduated from
high schools not to start college I got
a job at an arcade Oh
one of those that that pong being the
first to keep the language good I'm
gonna say holy cow it's it's five six
years later and it's not one thing it's
multiple you know arcade machines with
various games just holy cow head and
shoulders above what came before it and
even when they try to do some of those
games on the atari they yeah yeah it
just wasn't the ticket I think it was
amazing
yes but I'm but I in college for you
know two or three years 12 years give or
take I dropped out join the military
okay let's get to it it's all good guy I
dropped out and then they made me an air
traffic controller I always just get a
cuz that's like a really hard job yeah
really you it was just one of those
things
mm-hmm but
they sent me to Germany okay well
actually prior to that some was in that
I bought the Atari 5200 652 iota 50 -
yeah Wow it was awful they were a little
bit better but you can hardly play them
because of the crap controller and yeah
yeah so but anyway I'm now and um that
was actually bought for me
mm-hmm you know my parents after that
now I'm paying for them mm-hmm Germany
now I went a little different I bought
an Atari 1040 ST okay mm-hmm and I'm
playing 16-bit games and by the time the
NES dropped I'm like yeah I'm not going
down to that I got really kind of snooty
about it three years I'm in Germany 85
to 88 I just had that that that 1040s T
mm-hmm next couple years didn't do a
whole lot of gaming after that I was in
the mobility and I was getting sent all
over the world okay and it was it was
unreal in 24 months 16 of those months I
was down everywhere we took during that
period there wasn't much game you were
moving around the moment I say yeah well
I was living in Louisiana at the time
but my actual home unit was down in
Florida at Patrick Air Force Base okay
and I was like I went they didn't call
him combat controllers but we were kind
of part of that like if they wore some
warriors army Marines whatever right
hand with combat controllers and they
direct and planes into the airfield and
once that airfields control then we show
up with a mobile radar equipment mobile
tower and then we start bringing planes
in and out that job was whenever suicide
question cut you for a second because
you got my mind thinking or something
mark my question for you as a game right
this is a complete side sidebar as it
gave her being with you in the Air Force
and you dealing with that level of air
traffic control or that did air traffic
games did flight simulator games ever
appeal to you or was it something
because you're doing a real thing you
like not it's this ain't it I was just
curious about your perspective god I
loved them okay actually has been some
air traffic
troll simulator games on PCs and in the
flat sim games mm-hmm uh amazing I'm so
looking forward to that flies but I
flight with my Cancellara guy I was just
browsing continue with your story about
you go back we have in years later I
ended up getting a tolerating so I was
both Bo radar tower but at that time I'm
radar only which was way harder than
being in the tower anyway but yeah I
wasn't worried about to be honest I went
about playing games I was worried about
can I do this my job and great but they
get trained and you get you do it you
know it is what it is but anyway after
traveling all over the world in that
mobility unit it was causing real
problems at home you know with the what
is now the ex-wife so when the whole
Panama invasion thing happened I was
down there for that well and so they
come around saying hey we've made all
the families they went home like two
months ago some of five six months ago
and just let the military member there
and because they did that to him but if
the military guy or gal had another two
years three years to go on their tour
once once we got rid of no egg and
cleaned everything up there they let
those people go back to the states and
then do a permanent change of station so
they needed people to refill those slots
desperately and they were just walking
around and take your name and without
even thinking that's bad of my shirt so
a little while later another about a
year mm-hmm I'm in the Middle East go
for one Wow it's amazing I'm in the
military and I'm in a war Wow Wow
we're traveling around we're drawing out
new approaches for various some runways
that we just built in the middle of
nowheres in the desert sad they called
it mmm we just laid that runway out and
I was of course I was still low ranking
and mostly I was carrying equipment but
to do part of it baby that's how some
women come up to me one day and said hey
you're on the airplane tomorrow you've
got orders to Panama mmm no do you
understand this is what this
what I'm in for I'm in will hear about
the snow here but sighs later I'm on an
airplane going back home mm-hmm a month
after that I'm down in Panama in beach
blue sky wasn't thinking yeah this sand
is a whole even crazier one of the guys
down there just come from Japan mm-hmm
he had where you got a pink steam engine
oh let's get to it let's get going
oh yeah so now I've got I got rid of
that Atari
1040s T okay all right get back it's
already 90 because I got in Panama 90 so
it's 90 okay PC engine the actual
Japanese you know we had like four games
what games yeah what gives you a four
that PC engine let's talk about it would
you have goals and goals there kid the
kid courage yeah well kid carriage but
the okay let's get to it
anyway blazing lasers of course several
just shrimps or spaceship shooters or
whatever you want to call them
mm-hmm so what I started doing them
mm-hmm being an air traffic controller
and flight crews coming in and out all
the time I would just gather up as much
money as I could I could afford mm-hmm
and do crazy things like handoff 200
bucks hundred bucks to it got air crew
guy boom actually gonna fly back to the
States and hand that money up different
air crew guy who was going to Japan Wow
crossing my fingers and hoping he
brought back the right you know right
gave a little yeah leap up yellow
post-it notes mm-hmm on the money itself
with the list but hey you gotta do what
you gotta do to get
don't you gonna do hold on one quick
second book bones I just got super trash
out the cat daddy fast axe fire on
something much love to my
brother-in-arms mojo on the mic and the
ones in the chat you already have my
respect he also mentioned about him
being stationed at Patrick Air Force
Base as well over at Cocoa Florida are
you familiar just well ok yes we do so
continue the story you have post it's
one of the money with the list a repeat
that again that you needed to get it had
to go from one if what's got or whatever
Air Force guys let's just get to it baby
me even when they got the games and they
would hand it off to somebody else the
games mmm it might go through a couple
crews before somebody was flying down to
Panama and I would get my games too much
later I just listen mojo those are true
importance I know you can order stuff in
the back of the magazines and things
back then in the day but I had people
that were going to Japan so I was I was
more than willing to risk it it worked
out most of the time I got a couple bad
games here and there I've never got many
games I think years later when I
actually sold the system off and and I
got the full PC engine with the CD all
in wouldn't but I sold what few games I
had and the original PC engine but now
while I'm down there I give it Genesis
in the base exchange and get games for
it so so I'm rocking loving the system
and then for whatever reason I kept
seeing people have these like multi 256
games in one which meant it had like
five games on it by the way multi core
you know they sold you know down on the
economy in Panama City
mmm-hmm I'm saying pen in my mouth about
the country Panama City in it so yeah
I'd went ahead and jumped on NES and
this word comes from one of those again
it's now what about 92 I think or
whenever when Super Mario Brothers 3
come out that was another one of those
holy cow moments oh yeah
I've been kind of snobbish I played that
the shoot-'em-ups and things like that
mm-hmm but I considered Mario a little
kids game and I was an arcade guy back a
you know I really had seen Mario won
playing stuff and didn't get it because
I wasn't playing it myself right - never
even thought this no no it's not getting
a real Mario game and I'm your left
reading magazines at the time I had
several subscriptions so but when Martha
more most three came out not playing
that oh my and it took me like a month
but I mean it while y'all were at that
time was working and had a baby evening
so mm-hmm
yeah another holy cow minute nice Mario
Mario crazy game mm-hmm after that kids
more traveling over the ps1 I'm
stationed out in California now and I'm
backing another mobile unit you know
traveling to Korea back and forth so
gaming is kind of spotty at times but
mostly just ps1 I skipped out on the n64
I was so upset not so much the staples
cartridges was your thing they slice the
data pipe so it was never it wasn't it
was barely a 32-bit system I don't
reckon it's 64 yeah whatever so anyway I
jump to the ps1 so holy cow moment with
that which was maybe four games well it
was only one with the ps1 there's a lot
of those 3d games didn't hold up well
but Metal Gear Solid this one was not
realized yeah
3d it's different is the thing and
eventually years later I get an n64 and
played Mario and then realized crap
Nintendo yeah
even back then they had it on the 3d it
was amazing but again like I said I was
traveling so much sometimes I've even
took my ps1 with me I had some little
speakers that had a little sub with it
mm-hm and hotel room I was in said it
was pretty
nice found the ps2 I just kind of given
up on anything but saw me soul
ps2 its DVD player oh yeah cute movie
guy so you know I'm picking up bootleg
movies and looted a bootleg spa in Korea
salute on the main shopping drag selling
he's taking import store but now we're
not ps2 I've read everything about the
OG xbox and I'm I don't like it
Microsoft I think evil the Empire and
all that lot of people do and I thought
they were pushing so heavy for computer
type games and talking about online
talking about online and I had in my
head just like I had in my head before
that I was wrong about arcade and these
little consoles can't be good and then
ain't turned out to be better off
because of the depth you could get in
games and things right I didn't think
online no you got to be couch cold you
gotta be friends sitting around each
other I didn't get it until I've been
all all night kid you not steady not
drinking doing bad things
I'm wrong I don't know what time I've
ever gone to bed don't even maybe a
couple hours later stationed over there
lived on the base I was just a temporary
duty in the hotel room came down beating
on my door and and I've been stationed
with him before and he knew I was a
gamer he was a game he's like yeah I
come right now you gotta see this
okay what was it let's get tile we go to
one of the fighter squadrons and in one
of their big rooms where they do Mass
briefings and got they got three got
screen the overhead projectors and then
there's like eight really nice CRT said
in like a half circle around Big Bang oh
yeah they got anything going everything
hooked at hundreds of pizza boxes he
paid a patient it's all these young
lieutenant pilots and yet there's also
some young enlisted guys in there
playing games together
mmm-hmm I stood in the back of the room
and just kind of watched what was going
on when that was another holy cow oh
yeah I understand what Microsoft's
trying to do and push and
and yeah that became the future oh yeah
uh please Toby halo was on that
projections okay okay that's what I
wanted to hear right oh yeah that left
from there and went and ball and I
bought it off base so they actually I
bought it off I think I bought it on
base and took it to one of the loft
based shops and they they did things to
it you're not supposed to do it was
really nice actually have another one
that's just soft martyred or whatever
but actually has a hard drive in it too
it's full of stuff but this one had
actually been modded internal leaning
that a little switch on it so you can
actually be online and you could flip
that switch and then yeah you were I'm
now in Korea full-time not just their
TTY I'm stationed there got my kids with
me I'm divorced now okay and yeah we had
the 360
we bought it towards the end that while
we were over there and by that time my
oldest udderly turned into a PC
master-race he didn't move from the
whole ops had been consoles in fact the
youngest one because the oldest one
would haul get the consoles I end up
start buying him all the handouts so
from like the gameboy color on yet every
one of them all the way up through
account the switches a handheld losing I
don't I don't play it like that but he
still got a 3ds he's about to take with
him when he goes in Germany he's got the
advanced and a 3ds and then his switch
well I left the switch over there so
it'll be waiting for me gets there but
anyway we did he's asking Oh son or
kunsan okay I did it
I had I did do a year kunsan but at this
point in time I'm up at osong where I
got the kids with me when I was it was a
true remote I was down there by myself
mm-hmm yeah somebody knows the [ __ ] and
those
this is for him since he knows those
places they called me the mayor of
Sontag Street salute to the lol salute
where we just revered this it right
there with mojo continue sir so yeah but
like so basically I guess I just wanna
interject for a second um you know
because of your travel you've been all
over you know obviously Air Force has
your station and and just moving your
family around like I find it pretty
amazing how you were determined to still
get access to gaming and I just wanted
to just touch real quick just what the
challenge is you don't it's obviously a
lot of trust and a lot of your fellow
comrades to be able to get stuff for you
live and moving things around you know
get it digs around to you but like like
how were you getting your information
like how are you able to stay abreast as
to what's really going on in the gaming
scene with how much you were moving
around in the military
subscribe to magazines mmm
improv acts an Atari ST magazine those
years I was in Germany I always hate
console war even back again I hate it
doesn't meet you guys they got more
games than the STV and it used to just
make up console wars I'm always win also
so we came back we're now back in the
states are out in Northern California
and that's when I picked up the second
we got back because the ps3 had already
been out I'm long but I went ahead and
picked one up I managed to get it
original fat boy that would play all ps1
and ps2 games yes the film and grill a -
I loved it
the one that did the big deforming rule
that had all the inputs yes yeah I was
about to listen I always thought Sony
made some really good-looking systems I
I love their designs on a system even
the fat boy even though my dues had
jokes about the fat boy he was able to
do everything that you needed him to do
you can pop and play your old games
that's when it was about back Capac
there will not be in the police station
[Music]
we them too so and I've got it I've got
a wee mm-hmm I talked about like naughty
things but it's got a hard 5 terabyte
hard drive GameCube game that every time
out every we game that ever come out its
I don't know you know well I'm actually
going I don't care my camera one kind of
point over to it I think it was actually
in the camera you can kind of see that
little wee over the corner below one of
the CRTs cameras off right now is are
you good GameCube much later I didn't
get it when it was out cuz I just
thought man that but the fact they went
they went disc was great but then they
went crazy and went with a little one
yeah and I should have I always
underestimate that hinders ability to
put out great games like I said I'd skip
to 64 and I I didn't totally skip the
GameCube but it was torture they already
painted a cycle generation I went when I
bought it
mm-hmm so but things were going pretty
good had those systems and they said by
then the youngest is now much older and
he's already it will start turning into
a PC Magazine which meds approves he
said you guys some good sons right there
you proves of the PC bastard so then I
get out retired 24 years and a day
mmm-hmm I'm out of the Air Force I get a
pretty good job I've actually had
doubled up for a year cuz I well when I
got back to the states I had two teenage
sons and they're like oh guess what in a
like a month our units deploying to the
desert mm-hmm I'm not no no no my mom
just had
no way I have anybody that to watch or
take care of them I just could not go
right so I was already over 20 years
anyway so I whipped out them retirement
papers and throw them on the desk going
on I'm done on you know I would have
went and indeed a bit kind of said I'm a
rocker well almost a year because when
you return from overseas you old in 12
months okay it's part of like how they
save money on the whole move stuff some
that's fine they made me stay here but
I'd already been putting in applications
and I got hired by mega billion-dollar
company not me okay I can see it and I
make so then I work in a while and all
the control I won't say the name of the
company not salute the school take down
one and Xbox one day one edition Wow and
and even though I played more on my ps3
than I did a 360 because I'm not a
shooter or was it you know dude bro
whatever I just reload you to go to
shoot or do a bro Call of Duty quick
story on that is after we got back and
let me come on you I'm retired
one day I throw it in it had to be I'm
preachers more called these I don't know
but I'm like you know I'm putting a game
I've been gaming since early seventies
mmm-hmm thirty seconds yeah but to be
water probably a seven or eight-year-old
that moment the kitchen just head said
you know I'm gonna stick I know where
you at Bulls you because I'm tell you is
you get old all that fast twitch stuff
go right out the window and I'm like you
know what I'm gonna let attic to them
have that that is Navi I cannot keep up
with all that that is a different skill
set man when you're young you're all
into that so I feel you continue now
it's 2013
mmm-hmm at the xbox one day one my look
controller to I feel that that original
the one they still had
they've only made like one improvement
to it yes I think the best consults have
been made I don't consider the that's
Eckstrom you gotta pay for and all that
and I'm not saying that the dual shocks
are bad or anything like that it's just
but I just think they Microsoft didn't
get that right when people are like the
DualShock 4 is just a huge improvement
from the DualShock 3 okay we're
comparing like crap - crap the Xbox
controller just add that whole alignment
with the analogs and stuff like that I
get it the uniformity of the two works
for whoever likes it I mean some people
are allergic to milk in there you know
they can't and they still love drinking
milk I mean they should drink the milk a
lot of people feel about that 360
controller okay a lot of people's
feeling I was the best one too but uh
continued mojo wrap-up cause being a
movie guy things I already had a early
adopter on a 4k TV already I changed it
out one a couple years later when better
ones came out luckily I was able to sell
that one and get a good chunk of my
money back but I'm so after a year in my
mall a base-model
ps4 okay so not on both and then when
the pro come out mmm
I waited a little bit on it because it
all still was about it it's not that big
of upgrading stuff but when they
actually did that little second upgrade
to the ps4 will you ride ass through I
went ahead and traded in my ps4 on the
pro and got OVR and all that Joker so
that's cool though right now that's in
my son's gaming area did you know only
console gaming he does is on the ps4 VR
one of y'all did you do did you not do
the X during that time when after yes I
here's the thing and I did buy the X day
one the year prior I bought an S model
just because it had the 4k right
one of those so but I didn't I didn't
sell my ass just kind of put aside I
still got the og model in the living
room on my 1080p TV but it's there on
big screens it's still good for movies
mm-hmm basically kind of have them all
and when the switch came out I actually
bought that for myself I figured he was
way too old for but it was I was still
thinking of it like a handheld he had
all the Gameboy switch TV so that's
pretty cool that having to move stuff
nice put out yeah and then you know from
2013 oh no actually when I was
researching the switch because I was
hoping the Tendo was gonna come out with
an amazing next-gen console that was
gonna be more powerful than the ps4
that's box so I'm watching every video
possible I'm really I mean I'm on
YouTube like crazy I'm researching stuff
and you know what most of those videos
people just kept talking bad about Xbox
mm-hmm I mean even on the big shows you
know and some of those signs that's when
I got really like wow you know what and
then I started finding people shows like
yours some other folks that were doing
stuff they were like you know games
games games gaming system it's all good
game I whatever you want it didn't know
that stuff didn't matter and probably
watching any of that other stuff cuz I
just got tired of hearing that and
negative my food and even at the worst
you think by 21 2017 late 2016 even the
worst time and they still got a pub G
that year and we had the right out of my
head you know Microsoft still pushing
out good games at that period of time
and they were acting like you know they
weren't pushing out good games at that
very time
Pub G listen I was whip up G all the way
up until now all right I tried to stick
my toe back in that water boy I gotta
get really acclimated to it I feel you I
feel you
cuphead was the one else I know didn't
have as many good games during the same
period time that maybe Sonny was
dropping mm-hmm but they they got stuff
until they because they were they were
transitioning from where they used to by
second party games right till they were
getting these studios and getting their
ducks in a row and hey that's that was a
business decision they made and you know
what I think it wasn't good one and now
I got my one small little rant two
minutes three minutes
that's about game pass let's get it and
the importance of it let's go people
I even on the beginning said well
whatever I don't care game passes for me
I like to own my games mm-hmm I have 630
games right now on a hard drive actually
on two hard drives that's the internal I
still find stuff on game paths I won't
play and now every new game I don't but
here's the thing this is important this
will come back to that s model here in a
minute it's pretty bad they're not
advertising this they're advertising it
to us we already know about it the
gaming community I need to see some
commercials for game pass on what
lifetime some channels you get single
moms with kids
she can't example hmm I'm sitting in a
Waffle House
afterwards I get over like 6:00 in the
morning I mean and I had a under my work
shirt and almost said the name of a
gaming shirt Dragon Ball Z shirt oh
let's get it then anyway I had it and
she started talking about gaming and she
was kind of meaning it she felt so bad
because she had like a six and an eight
year old didn't she couldn't go buy a
500 or console she couldn't our games to
keep games for him they'd been donated I
think like a ps2 is what they had
Tom and even that she couldn't go in and
could afford to get like use games and
things for him right and it made me feel
so bad but just I'd already bought an ex
and jaidev's formerly Kratos and
whatever else he calls himself now man
I'm doing this for you I like you and
your military career and your sons
that was my son first anything you want
you know whatever you want that as a
gentleman look trust me no matter glue
no we know it's people trolling on
Twitter but he's he's a good dude now I
got a free ex I got that ass on the back
of my car I didn't want to like offend
this person and just try to I'm just
gonna give him something so I'm like
mm-hmm
can you afford like 60 bucks mm-hmm
and she said come back come back next
week
mm-hmm come back one week later I sold
her my s model for 60 bucks and I get it
I got her a year of game okay one year
now you're good you're gonna get back
then I was saying 100 games cuz I didn't
realize they were gonna be 200 like it
is right kind of games now when Aaron's
gonna talk about all the games cuz there
were people out there and I'm not
talking about poor being honest on
middle that's why I'm walking proud this
single moms and I was a single parent
mm-hmm and like you mentioned earlier
where I tried to always keep gaming in
that Stephin of mine whereas in the
world yeah there are people that can't
do that a waffle house she was the boss
she had two kids and now her kids get to
play halo Master Chief collection
play Gears of War yeah good deed for me
and then I can turn around try to do a
good deed for somebody else on it but my
thing is I just want to see Microsoft
push that more not just to the gaming
community right that's if the customers
immediate start that's a great point
game pass would being I know all those
years when I was doing that and I was
trying
by these various systems and keep games
a couple times I dropped about hints
about you know shady systems and you
don't game pass you don't got to do that
I could tell right one year she's gonna
pay ten bucks a month she can like to
put her card in right it's safe it's
Microsoft don't worry about it's not
Sony Oh shots
I gotta interrupt you for was it cuz you
dropped so many bombs with that whole
stories I got Fresno salute to kratos
off time it was in front of the realm
you know I'm saying that definitely
PlayStation brethren we troll a lot we
go out but it's all in good fun and I'm
glad to hear that story because a lot of
people don't hear that aspect of of him
and he doesn't I know he doesn't promote
a lot but salute the cradles in that
number two shot to uh restored Hades
with the fire on a super chat I really
like that you're giving this game of the
spotlight new blood is important and
refreshing amazing show this given
Sunday thank you restored Hades then I
want to shout our anchorman he was
asking specifically away from and if you
are Tennessee we got a link you up with
Playstation bra and um he thinks he
knows what where he thinks he knows
where the soda company is he was open it
was NC but we're gonna get it we got to
blow that up you don't blow that up
there mojo live right now currently the
Knoxville Tennessee now I'm originally
from about two hours from here in what
they call the Johnson City Kingsport
area I went to I went my couple years in
college for a drop down at East
Tennessee State University of there but
uh yeah and I would have probably just
stayed out in California but because of
my mother's health was deteriorating and
I wanted to get my could have my kids
and to be able to see her before and
after about two years here she did pass
away so it was great Pepsi Michael
Jackson's mad at you right now let me
transfer here you that was so great just
salute brother so no man keep keep it up
and I love I love what you said about
game pass because again you know I had a
little rant last week about pocket
watching but again it's it's like you
say I think you made a great point
they're gonna be even the casual games
forget the hardcore game who don't who
doesn't even know about this and they're
looking at it like hey I'm a just
afford one system you know and here's
this option that's gonna give me all
these games right dad is amazing now the
last thing I want to shout all shout to
our brother every week man this is
really humble yeah well my hood man the
$50 suit chat almost missed the Lord's
playing modern Wilfred thank you folks
for sticking with us brother every week
is always good to see you man much much
appreciate it man I can talk to you all
day okay guys we got let us know but
well we'll get today I ever get you know
we got our you ready uh he listens to I
open he's I got my top five he's like ah
she ate I don't give in the chat I still
watch you guys thank you thank you oh
you have no idea how much that means to
us and the fact that like I said from
every generation to have that type of
you know participation with the show is
humbling what I wanted to get to I just
wanted to sidetrack for seconds we're
gonna do that top five you know we're
gonna do that but my question is how I
came across to you was through Lord
mines gaming and I'm saying so shout the
llamas Lords gave me got net and his own
channel and of course the next-gen
podcast so I want to know how did you
link up with mods to get that going and
I believe it's you and uh Jimmy Moran
right you guys did oh yeah right so
let's get that going as far as the um
you know next-gen podcast well when I
like I said back when I was got kind of
researching the switch and I was
watching video not only mostly none
other names but bigger Internet entities
yes everyone I started switching to just
regular gaming community folks that were
doing shows come across some of his
videos of some of his very first videos
and here was a guy that one video would
talk about how good xbox is and what he
thought that the ex was gonna be existed
prior to being released in the next
video he'd be talking about how great
the ps4 pro was gonna be I was like I
had to kind of lean over a little bit
and listen to make sure I understood him
yeah those early videos but and he just
kept getting better and he was always
just yeah the infant would be there
and then wow I don't know when I
actually can't remember with it with it
with the contact me at some point saying
hey I'm gonna do a show we might have
been on another show I've done a couple
of boom shows yes I saw you on boom
yeah salute the ball so but at some
point and I think maybe I already talked
to him about Rhenish things to
contacting myself cuz he's he's one of
those guys if you were wondering about
something and she messaged you know he
will uh he don't let me be s either I'm
like - man he's like give me the week
give me the link yeah yeah don't be weak
so much and I'm like people don't
believe me I don't care it's the
Internet I can say anything oh yeah
that's why look that's why we love mods
he once told fax he was still sources
we're not just gonna be talk all bad
luck after the show Cindy weeks right my
head of time and Jamie he's my Twitter
brother I just came across him because I
worked 12 hours over nine this is why
they won't say the name of the company
I'm playing on Twitter sometimes I'm
waiting to do certain things where I
just gotta be yeah you got that down
ties literally yes out the braaap with
the to our super chat does mojo play
that Les Paul it's a nice guitar I'm
putting together a little show that I'm
calling mojo's mmm-hmm milkshakes and
movies and I've been trying to record a
little intro I'm not using the guitar
and stuff so we'll see how that comes
out that's gonna be the intro to that
show and now I'm gonna make I doubt this
1950s vintage diner milkshake maker okay
amazing so I'm gonna make milkshakes and
while they're make you know getting
around stuff I'm gonna talk about
various movie or something and see if I
can get any traction on that cuz you
know I do that laser just picking the
day on Twitter maybe I saw other
laserdisc loved it I said this we got
the CRTs and then later
he isn't the one on the right reminds me
of my yeah well you know right go what
are you going to write look like that my
skin their solve had cuz we know he
thought it was full 1080p mojo we had to
call him out not today but real quick
before you move on to the top I question
for you is like I said because we see
you are such a traditionalist mojo like
it what's your thought process of
holding on to the tech holding onto
those monitors holding on to all the
consoles like what's your mindset is it
something that you want to go back to at
any point or do you still appreciate the
quality that was given at that time I
love everything that's going on now in
the gaming world but I'll probably play
more on my Sega Saturn lay down what's
my all-time favorite console I'm gonna
say the PC engine slash turbo graphics
there we go that's my man right there
right I will probably play more Saturn
now right now than the other ones cuz I
got in the other room I got a big 32
inch chunky CRT absolute perfect shot
and shooter games and talk to self
mojo more than you got to check out Sega
Lord X on YouTube say Gillooly see our
T's what movie for the laserdisc laser
discs were in boxes in the bottom of a
closet I don't forgot mm-hmm that means
I so right when DVDs were about to hit I
realized that crap I need to get rid of
these cuz they're going away a doorway
DVD will be the future mm-hmm so I sold
about half the collection and got pretty
much every penny that I'd already spent
on laserdisc back I did real well on it
smaller store out in San Francisco at
the time
but I'm anyway I bought Lisi our tickets
just for retro gaming once I've gotten a
couple of my life not a laserdisc player
somewhere
well the stereo system in my bedroom
that I use just for CDs for high-end
transport on it mm-hmm
okay all these laser discs I'd forgotten
about him so I dragged all that stuff
out and look things up and I haven't
stopped since I have fun with all this
people think I'm a retro guy I get so
upset sometimes I see certain retro guys
that just build their channel on that
one thing and they act like no I love
modern gaming I want that I want the
Anaconda scarlet or whatever you want to
call it in the PS 5 mm-hmm I love the ex
and the pro and we are magazine but I
also love 2d side-scrolling yeah you
like oh it's a diversity but I don't
plan those games on a nice CRT I've got
the little all the little minis I have
every one of them NES classic super
nimble a song anyone I've got one that's
arcade one collagen from retro bit just
as arcade games on it okay okay and I've
got the already pre-ordered the pc
engine and trouble kind of 16 when i've
ordered both so when those drop I love
them and it's great watching them on a
4k set or a 1080p set but it's still I'm
telling you and you play those real
games it's a different even if you're
just playing
there's using an ever drive or something
you got the wrongs you're playing on the
real equipment and it's it's pitch
perfect and they're just so fast the way
CRTs are designed and how the nuances
and graphics and things on those little
games they're just meant to be played on
it and so as long as I can't sometimes
I've got the both the the Super Nintendo
classic
as well as the Japanese version swap and
then I've got ruins mm-hmm so I think
you going back and forth
you see here right beside that modern
now look at him on stuff and I'm like
just happen I want to I want to add a
topic so we replace parts often you uh
make sure exclusive oh solutions you
know that we'll get to that we get rid
of your table that's that time we got a
lot discuss file but we would never show
the value the shroud and all this mixer
moving but look we got a move on a lot
of show to go but so we got to do what
Lord mojo has prepared for astutely he
knows what the royal treatment is about
so Lord mojo that last question we asked
all the guests on the realm I mean that
top five video game or franchises of all
time let's get it okay like everybody
else this tends to change from time to
time but I'm gonna cheat to something I
haven't where honorable mention a little
bit okay let's say it's not not a game
not a franchise it's a genre and that's
the shoot-'em-ups okay chunks I love
them even some of the modern indeed
versions put out here you know over the
last two three years
mmm-hmm I just like that stuff so that's
my honorable mention okay number five
let's go
what was L Wow bends while amazing mmm
for the switch play that's right you
said no no you said the correct one you
say it with your chest are Breathitt
well I thought I did
continues love him already he's welcome
back in the row those elbows five number
four is a combination Metroid
Castlevania Metroidvania games but just
to know I did not like Metroid Prime
okay still don't not I kind of hate the
fact that Nintendo's doing that next I
wish they would do another 2d Metroid
game but a 2d stuff the castlevanias
mmm-hmm and the Metroid's it moved on
from the consoles to the Gameboy so
anyway that's my number four before
Farini I gotta give kijima some love
gimme ur which one all of them bought a
franchise okay yeah franchise and even
going back to a couple of games even the
one he did on the NES and so for some
NEC computer in Japan it's not sure that
eventually got him say this and there's
some stuff from Metal Gear in snatcher I
don't know would you know go with later
so franchise was number three yes right
number two and this one just recently
come back on to the list because of the
Resident Evil 2 remake but I'm going
Resident Evil French that's your horror
that's your horror affinities right oh
yes I've no doubt I know it that is a
PlayStation 1 those tank controls so
don't take a joke I played the first one
I think it I didn't last two minutes I
must have been three four days in a row
I never went more than two minutes
without dying our PlayStation are into
it good things out but again I have the
Internet to run - Oh daddy tried to get
a range of getting them YouTube tips we
had those salute and that's pretty
modern I mean Resident Evil's just drop
what seven not too long ago and about
the new I'm talking about the old one
I'm talking about Owen we had to take
controls PlayStation one day boom era
you know I'm saying when you were stuck
it was few sources you could go to that
I'll just you know bringing that up for
the deal current generation that's run
my favorite youtuber and find out how to
get past something
now I don't know how to start yelling
for my son yeah my favorite owner is the
darksouls John Durr okay you can look up
all the information you want don't you
he could look at me he wanted to it
don't mean he go get it done no Doug
salut so let's go resume the double word
sir number one number one I'm going
Mario franchise mmm yeah one of those
holy cow moments when I played Super
Mario 3 when I realized that the depth
that you could have in a game compared
to just say an arcade machine I was like
oh I gotta go back Mario 1 now into
within two but anyway one in three Super
Mario World just knocked it out of the
park during that time chill dude even
now that not just breath of wall but on
the Wii U they had a 2d Mario Luigi and
then crossing Mario franchise I count
like Luigi games to there yes what did I
say it's all encompassing
and my waist is a little Nintendo heavy
with but it's also you know Metro
Council range so that's you know we love
this you're less me don't have too much
new stuff you know you know what I said
Resident Evil still going strong mm-hmm
Mario still going strong I mean you know
Mario Odyssey is just found yep
I was really wild and their mother who
know it about to do brother stuff but
from now I might be throwing something
completely different in there I just I
come and go and change though yo salute
to the list man absolute pleasure with
that list some clashes in there google
chat I know I'll get it real quick
always read stitches super so find out
chat from stitch King what happened to
that PS energy in the outer words I hear
nothing about crickets on that side I'm
a tiny stitch I think you want some
you know did you purchase this week sir
did you go on in your $65 did you know
what's funny about that all the time
like to like have this persona if you
get a review copy you're automatically
bought like are we gonna have like
different reviews for if you have paid
$60 you got a review copy yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're hearing a lot of stuff right
now I'm hearing on some news so breaking
news going on during the show by the way
um obviously the Italian thing we're
hearing about and of course I'm we're
hearing rumors of overwatch 2 has been
released so that we got a couple of
breaking things you may try to touch
lightly but we got concept arts about
that a couple of months ago yeah man we
got some stuff we're gonna get into lots
of show so we gonna move on we got to
pull you know I'm saying that we're
gonna jump in so the winner of last
week's poll result spot in the people
have spoken to the question with the
September MPD results of gears 5
finishing number seven overall and
number three on the Xbox one in dollar
sales do you consider this a sales flop
or the gears franchise the winner of the
three-way ILP poll at 63% is the no game
pass is a success in Gears 5 is still in
the top 10 without steam sales coming in
at second place at only 20 percent was
the yes Xbox flagship franchise can't
top crack top three MPD nor number one
on its own platform sad laugh
lastly at seventy percent was that I
don't care
I'll count anything for one dollar
subscription free through jad did a
Robocop references it of the poll this
week
Lauren attic man did the people they say
that this is a good deal they said it
was a good thing for you sir I mean at
least we know some people any drink in
the juice some people are sincere and
actually know what's going on like
sometimes I feel like these people don't
even know what day the week it is what
year the week questions you ask the
people with the ambulance like what's
the present these people Oh salute
salute Lord act we got another poll cook
it up baby we'll get into the show we
got some good topics today
Oh Oh is that noise of gaming dotnet oh
is that fellow next-gen podcaster my man
Lord mods gaming what's up it absolutely
no dagger damn it around brother good
you answer the call
we got mojo in the building and my sorry
dude next Jedediah Pete collabo right
now so you already know it it is but we
will get into it man we got a lot of
discussion and on soft man what is going
on to some some games that dropped this
week for short you want me to talk about
first all right let's go Daisy he was
all sweet with a jump me laugh leaves of
a baby
there will be no switch this discussion
on this word for you Eric wants to bring
it up yeah go pre order that Luigi's
Mansion 3 thank you anyway I think so
what about we we set it off with I think
we all have a lot to say about other
words let's set off with CEO D because I
know a few of us didn't play I know I
didn't get to play it so yeah just your
impressions will start with steel
dealing with his transition so for me I
haven't played Cod in a long time like I
just I fell off the series I only really
came to the series for the single-player
stuff and I just got tired of it like it
feels like every single you like the
game feels the same you could drop in
whatever different scenarios whatever
different time periods it still feels
they all feel the same to me
and it to me anyway um so coming back to
modern warfare that was the last time I
really felt like wowed by a Call of Duty
monitor the first modern warfare and I
played all the campaigns for all three
modern warfare as up until now um so I
wanted to come back to this in addition
to that I heard a lot of the original
team had come back left respawn and come
back to work on this so I really wanted
to see what they could do and I'm gonna
be honest with you like it's it's more
Call of Duty it's more Cod I honestly
was a little disappointed by the fact
that it's it just fits right into what
what I thought cod was and having been
away from him for a couple of years I
was really disappointed that I felt that
same way I wanted more from it so I've
only played a couple of hours into the
campaign and it's beautiful I get a
gorgeous game you can tell that the
engine has been refined and improved
considerably it looks really great I'm
playing it on the X it doesn't run the
best on the X to be perfectly honest
with you um it's not it's not a hundred
percent 4k all the way through I don't
think mom and you can see you can feel
some dips in framerate which for a cod
game is not something you expect at all
um so it's a it's mm it's not the smooth
experience if you have it on PC not you
for a second so I'm here now I want to
shout out mods I was looking at his
Twitter feed I'm hearing on this thing
is shutting Xboxes off I heard it
bricked someone's Xbox I heard it I
don't know what that's going on I think
[Laughter]
this is gonna get twisted and it's gonna
be the peasant s holders of the one it's
getting I think it was an ex that got
bricked if not if I'm not mistaken maybe
I'm wrong about that great yeah I mean
Xbox one is shutting down for many
people in that game and actually it's
like second game in like last couple of
weeks
as well right exactly right and so yeah
I mean I don't know what's going on with
that like maybe my Christine's to look
into it
maude um the fact that they're pushing
for K and other the ones can't
I mean if maybe that's the thing it's
not it's not staying a full caking it's
the only known after dynamic is their
overheating a turning off I mean that is
what it is but in terms of the gameplay
I'm gonna be honest like god it always
tries to - while you and blow you away
with like these are these controversial
things that happen in the campaign like
the game game starts out with a suicide
bombing and then it goes into you trying
to find these chemical weapons that get
stolen and then there's a big attack on
London and it's just like after having
seen you know no Russian back in the day
like that's the example and the cliff
notes of all caught you're right it
follows this pattern when it did it just
doesn't feel like it's trying to say
anything new you know what I mean so
continue grab the super chair best way
to play card is on PC yeah man it's just
it's more card I expected more for me I
was hoping more for me you know car you
know cog knows that I've fallen off the
show I love baseball and I've fallen off
the show as well just because of the
same thing like you're in and you're out
you're getting you know these these sort
of minimal upgrades and I just feel like
Ricardo even though you get a game every
year you get three different Studios
making these games that they have you
know three and a half to four years to
make each one of these games and it just
I know I know it's a director from
Activision where you know Cod has to
feel the same across the board it has to
sort of run so you can jump in and out
of it but I think it's to his detriment
it doesn't feel like it's saying
anything new does it feel like it's
doing anything new it's pretty it's
polished
um and I'm sure once I finish the
campaign it'll be it'll be fine but I
expected more from car any anyone else
our mods you picked it up right yeah but
I didn't play it for a long I mean like
I put like maybe 30 minutes into it
before the show and you know blame my
little slow internet so yeah but like
yeah it looks great it's obviously is
having performance issues which is kind
of strange and this is yet another game
that is kind of like pushing the
resolution I think too much and you know
performance suffers so and you know like
this is the fact
I mean PlayStation 4 pro is running this
game better in terms of like performance
it's very close to 60 on PlayStation 4
pro on xbox one X is not really right -
sometimes it falls down to like 48
frames your mark you're right
sorry yeah here we go do you see a
little bit of frame pacing on the issues
as well on the X like it feels like it's
like a very slight hitch I haven't
noticed yet not not the answer I mean
like I'm very early into the game but I
already did see some kind of issues on
the title screen lord walder did you
pick up a call of duty this year did you
pick you know i i'm i'm a year later guy
I don't think I've ever bought anyone
when they dropped when they first
dropped
wait and then when I see a good price I
get it for the campaign okay
but I thought about this one cuz it was
a new engine and supposed to look great
and I was like you know what I think I'm
gonna buy this one mm-hmm
and then luckily I just held back one
second moto moto one one second oh you
take care that's all you need to take
care that they're coming for you I'm
happy to answer it so that's the Lord
can call it that Lord sob why is it okay
to say it's more card but you can't say
it's more gears yeah I said gears 5 is
more gears so it I mean but me I think
the difference is is when people play a
car game they expect a car game will be
played gears game for summers they
expect anything so I mean it but it goes
the same issue applies to both it's like
what gears I wanted him to do I wanted
him to do more I want to take the more
risks right and the risk that they did
take was kind of a dip their toe and do
they really go all the way with God it's
like man you can take more risks because
you come out every year like the fact
they didn't have a campaign last year I
understand why black ops for still did
as well as it did because people really
are just coming to this for the
multi-blade like the and and and and the
campaign the story beats the way it's
presented like addicts said like it's
par for the course you're gonna get some
big attack somewhere some something is
supposed to emotionally move you and
it's every single time it's the same
thing so it to me I mean I again I don't
know how the multiplayer is I don't know
how great it is or not yeah I mean it
for the campaign and in terms of the
campaign they haven't moved that needle
it still follows those same beats I want
I want to get two comments in each ad it
just shot the one bad mother--
I salute he said gears every three years
yearly cadence makes it more exhausting
with card and then he said I shot the
slow-mo he said what is this complaining
for he said the campaign was the best
thing everything I will say this up I
was surprised when I heard you say you
didn't like it because
I get out just my little answered a
little evidence out for people I see you
know on Twitter yeah people are raving
about this car they were like oh the
case not it it's not that I don't like
it okay cuz I don't think it's again the
last campaign that I completed mm-hmm
was modern warfare 3 not in complete
black ops I haven't completed anything
since then so the campaign like I said
it's good its polished it's just more of
the same and it file and to me at least
to now it doesn't deviate from those
standard beats like add why would add
able to point out exactly how a Call of
Duty game starts oh we should that since
advanced warfare exactly so it's one of
those things like up until now the only
character that seems super interesting
to me is the rebel leader Pharaoh
because again like she's in a Middle
Eastern country she she's in charge of
this rebel group so the fact that it's a
woman in charge and it you know the
things you would expect in terms of
culture in that part of the world like
it's it's a very cool sort of change of
pace of what you might expect but I
haven't played enough yet to see how
that character kind of unfold beyond
that everybody is very much you know
military dude you know what it is well
it's interesting because I said it he
does seem polarizing into chat you know
I've heard some things
mods again following your timeline I
heard some things about a shorter
campaign some people are saying they're
getting it done at 65 hover several
hours I don't know that's nothing new
for cardio they always say these
companies over these games are always
like short and you know another thing
you know another thing tell me about
that I was ok but 20 hours is it listen
I'm going to wise a phenomena I know
like he said the dubrow shoot a type of
thing it's not not for me I get it when
it's on sale just like you know on mojo
said you know I'm shout out some
Microsoft and
you know the new Xbox Dashboard there's
a little thing that you can click on to
aim and you can uh indicate when a game
goes on sale if you can put in your like
your wish list and you can indicate when
it goes on sale and you get a
notification telling you that the game
that you're looking for the game that's
on your wish list is on sale and you can
actually purchase it so if you don't
have the finances for a game right now
Microsoft Microsoft allows you that
you're able to put these games in you
wish list and when those games go on
sale you have a little indicator in it a
pop-up and it'll let you know that these
games is on sale so you don't miss out
on sales who did that for you Atticus
he's had enough Call of Duty paddle has
played let's get into it's off I'd
rather sleep the rest of my life to talk
about oh my god let's get into this
outer world obviously it dropped you
know um I believe every single member of
the roundtable today has plated I'm
hoping if not please let me know but um
soft man where you at with other worlds
you're tapping I tell you man I love
obsidian I've always loved the guy the
best old-school like see you know see
RPGs old-school baldur's gate stuff
obviously the guys on his team are
original fallout um they are they are
masters of the craft and the fact that
they now have the chance to do their own
IP I think it's fantastic I think they
hit it out of the park and they didn't
they didn't try to do too much with it
they didn't necessarily try to you know
be the next fallout mystic it were
realistic with it with the time and the
budget that they had and what they
created in fact is an amalgam of some of
my favorite things from fallout and Mass
Effect and put it into an interesting
funny world yes that is their own yes
and at the same time I think what
they've done with in terms of the
conversations and the way you can SPECT
differently and the way your it seems
like your decision to really matter in
this world I think you're really
starting to look at what we can expect
to Wow
in next-gen it's not gonna be graphics
it's not gonna be it's realizing these
worlds they don't have to be humongous
worlds but the fact that they're deep
and these characters are deeper and the
everything is I like the fact that
everything is voiced I love that oh I
think I think they really hit out of the
park I'm so happy for them
that they they have another game out
there that are kind of appeals to the
masses because I pillars of eternity is
great but you know it's a it's an
isometric you know old old-style CRPG
it's not gonna appeal to everybody you
know you look at this game you see
fallout and if that it fall out of
something you love you Jimmy D Utley
gonna be drawn to it then once you start
cleaning it you feel mass effect and you
have not been happy with it oh yeah
you're gonna be drawn to it so honestly
man I'm kind of in love I'm only like
three hours in what everything I've seen
you know in terms of the systems and and
how you how they manage like the
character building and stuff like that
isn't fantastic it's tight another thing
that I'm happy about is the fact that
it's not really buggy like it's not that
it's my same smooth yeah it's kind of
smooth I'm like oh my goodness I used to
this I used to that charm of bugs is
that Microsoft bagman they got it but I
tell you like I'm really happy for them
and I gotta say and I know I think um
Joe mentioned this before I think my um
Xbox nation mmm I'm telling y'all right
now even though this game is a third
party game you need to treat it as if as
if it is a first party game meaning go
out there and support exactly
you know honestly unless your only means
of playing is a Playstation or if you're
waiting for the switch version for some
reason exactly you need to be playing
this game on game pass on PC on an Xbox
it's the smart thing to do let's go we
all get mods emotional and mods man I've
seen your timeline as well and I know
were highly anticipating this game your
excitement
probably probably the most I've seen you
excited for a game before it launched in
a long time am I kind of accurate with
that without a parry and that's for two
reasons I like RPG games mm-hmm
I played pretty much all Fallout games
excluding fallout 76 I'm talking about
those 3d Fallout games right I did play
those you know fallout 1 and 2 but well
they a bit too old and too like you know
my liking
yeah but like I like that kind of style
of games I like RPGs and I like shooting
as well so you know everything is in
that game to be honest with you and you
know also I was one of the I was one of
the you know people that was you know
when when the very first leaks about
some new studios being bought by Xbox
started I was one of those guys that was
like oh you know my crostinis to be by
obsidian and stuff and then what real
was that was actually spreading those
rumors that OH obsidian might be my get
bought and stuff I was like yeah and
yeah listen you know they are very
talented studio and I get that I know a
lot of people were saying that oh you
know some people that did work on
fallout you know last you know new vegas
are not there anymore and stuff right
people obviously you know you know come
and leave right
but generally speaking like if you look
at the portfolio or portfolio of their
games
well resume talk about that resume mods
let's get to it
I mean you know like you know the Star
Wars game right there the Knights of the
oh yeah obviously Fallout game you know
you've got you've got the creators of
the original Fallout games there as well
right so there's a lot of talent and you
know obviously they were struggling with
the budget for the last couple of years
you know actually it's actually a funny
story because Microsoft kind of you know
actually made
into misery actually you know lead them
into him a bit of misery and the very
beginning of this generation so it's
actually funny that actually they bought
it as a boat oh yeah so listen you know
obsidian you know I think it's one of
the best pick ups along with our
playground games and Ninja Theory yeah
my three big studios good list and yeah
I mean I I love the outer walls it's
like you know it's a combination of mass
effect and allowed games you know I've
put like four maybe five hours into it
so I mean I'm obviously I'm very very
beginning of the game but so far I'm
loving it and I love the humor right I
mean like I was joking with some people
on the humor and stuff and they love
humans hilarious man I mean I get to my
point whether I got like to say but I
know we gotta get mojo and I want
addicts so mojo did you pick up outer
world yet oh yeah okay okay
game of course Wow salute the gave a
salute though but yeah man I got back
home and I played I didn't play it
Friday night I waited oh crap I got
about three hours in and at one point
I'm like wow this is so good I'm
actually want to stop because I want to
kind of stretch it out I don't want to
just finish it over you know three five
days or something not not just the humor
but even the AI in it is it's excellent
for a game of that stars these guys know
what they're doing then mm-hmm yeah I
just keep getting amazed and I was
expected to be good but at the same time
you kept thinking that was gonna be
something that was know yeah it's
exactly what everybody wanted a really
great sci-fi RPG mmm could've been a
better time cuz I mean it's just what
Microsoft needed more RP and and
single-player and I like the size of the
game I don't want you know as great as
like Assassin's Creed Odyssey is preach
it brother
our shifts four minutes sometimes six
days a week
preach it all strumming I've been
averaging 60 hour plus weeks
had some 72-hour weeks mm-hmm don't
leave a lot of time for gaming then we
don't even if I can play sometimes I'm
just too tired
mmm like on a Sunday morning I might be
a man I'm throwing you guys on I'll be
able to go in the Lord's realm of Lords
I don't mind that hey Rach sometimes you
know I want to be able to retire from
working completely and I still got about
three four years and mm-hmm
I got to deal with it so what I can get
him like this oh it's perfect the right
side so he dropped something like that
you know God a war it was a great time
amount for it but we'll get away from
that just but outer worlds I know we
mentioned it some of the original guys
did the original fallout 1 & 2
idiot well some of the other ones that
worked on those games there at the the
dead that does wasteland yeah studios
now those guys x GS those game studios
is people may need to wake up getting
passes amazing and they got a bunch of
good studios it's gonna give you a
regular floor games and it's already
happening I mean how many games now you
know last horizon you know racing game
and then we gears and now we got outer
worlds and then we got some smaller
stuff coming and in there there's gonna
be halo and they've not announced a
couple of bigger games it's gonna come
maybe a little quicker and people think
some of Microsoft Studios can pump games
out in two years I mean they just can
they have they they put three hundred
five hundred two halfs everybody thinks
I don't know they've been working on
five years no they didn't actually they
might did some little pre-production and
things like that
but we actually green not those games
okay we're building it now I actually
like the actual dev time for steady
decay to was two and a half years yeah
it's sometimes people they think and I
know there are games that have taken
five years and things like that but when
you get up to 200 people great game no
bugs and you can get it out on time
most of when the game takes like five
years to make not that attended made
engine before they made that game
exactly right so let's get you an adding
I mean man you've been going back and
forth we've been talking about this game
so we're you I know you have put in a
ton of hours more than probably
everybody on the panel so just where
you're at what outer world and your
feeling on it what's up you know I was
really enjoying this game and then I
remember something Laura Coggan you know
what I remembered what you remember - I
remembered I played I paid that's I paid
nothing for this game just no pain
nothing you know I didn't pay $60 that
made it a worse games and I should be
playing so I turned it off I haven't
played a sense I'm like because you know
why I actually put money in destiny
stock though like it's justice by none I
really enjoy a lot of aspects about out
of wars what I like is they did what
Fallout 4 should have done and and the
fact that Bethesda keeps dropping the
ball at every corner we're getting to
King's topic later it's really really
easy to like it's sad when they're out
Bethesda but that's the mmm because I
will say that that game is miles better
fallout 4 mmm the reason you know I've
always said follow four is is a good
first-person shooter it's not a good
fallout this took that aspect what I
really liked is they did a little like
quality of life changes from all out to
this followed new vegas like for
instance and Fallout New Vegas you had a
level individual stats a bit level three
stats till they hit 50 and then you
loved all individual stats
what does King throw in something in the
bushes bushes continued down beyond
where you'll have a mutiny continue at
it before we kick Kings rev it up I
could sink a deep it comes to the game
though the only negatives that I really
see is automatic
I think the graphics aren't where they
should be get them they look you look
like that's something that would happen
like
end of last June the beginning of this
gym they don't tell them how to look
anything special you know I've always
been the kind of person the game plays
good enough I'll overlook everything
that's what's happening here
but I did the rocks the textures look
like someone just squirted like a 5 year
scored like crown on it why did that
come that's not these textures look and
I feel like the people that are posting
how beautiful this game look showing us
like the space thank you so what a
skybox what about the people who say
that you played on the Xbox
[Laughter]
y'all exaggerated he played on PC so he
said where it could be your your
personal experience could be the issue I
will say this though even on the X like
there's no HDR and I think for for a
game like this with it's so colorful HDR
would help it so much pop more looks
like garbage
no you know I'm saying that for a game
that's coming out at the end of this gen
you should okay obviously I think it's
because it's because the engine issues I
think they probably what's the same even
ran off Blues unreal unreal probably
didn't have a whole lot of time you said
I want to hear about how bad the visuals
are you plan on the equivalent of a Game
Boy Color advanced slow-mo always come
put you a timeout so I could talk
Wow a lot of things you just showed me
Val said man I'm gonna put you in the
butcher you know what I like about this
game isn't all new Vegas the majority of
the options it was one or the other
mm-hmm you didn't really have a middle
ground that sometimes you would but most
the time it was like you got to be bad
you got to be good we have no middle
ground here you know they're like you
could be bad or good and then we'll give
you a third option after you've done
that all the not all the negative stuff
and we'll let you fix what you started
mm-hmm now slow movies are you know but
we don't get you out baby SWAT write it
down for that that's what that work so
I'm a jump in I'll be okay go jump in
okay good job yes we are selling that
t-shirt that is on I'll put the link in
the description so yes we got listen we
got a hundred of 14 people watching do
me a favor and hit those likes yes
please um also hit that teespring stars
store for the throw them in the bushes
t-shirt if you feeling that not that Dad
we're not doing that or we're doing that
we got that snapback buddies Victor I'll
Stacy do you think outer worlds will
encourage a few multi clients or the
game pass something like this
disintegration from exhale Oh dev
interesting we get to that and then
shouted is new to our hash tag free
slow-mo I'm addict out here acting like
Blizzard reach out to slow down to get
this thing straight down continue
chopping off heads
alright so King you had a lot to say
okay just like adding me and haddock
talked about it you know I was playing
the game I was playing the game so hard
that I was falling asleep playing the
game from being tired you know from
coming from work and it jumping straight
on because a lot of you guys got a
chance to play from midnight on I'm
that's the beautiful thing about gaming
past you know if you happen to have it
then you could jump on so the game is
out and I think that is a wonderful
thing i pre-loaded that game long time
ago and then I got another notification
on my phone from game pass app I
downloaded on upstairs on Xbox so what I
feel about the game is yeah I love
fallout I think is the best for a lot of
shout out to anchorman I know you like
it too
the game does it look like Lau's Jim
yeah do ya do it is it's clean though
it's is the engine engine be a little
bit polished yes I want them to do like
one more up
we can get a like a seamless polish on
engine i feel the wear and tear of it
but i also think about it like this that
was their passion project that was
something that they was working on
Microsoft came along while he was
probably at the end of wrapping it up
and moving it forward and you know
purchased them and then cut you King but
the rumor is again I want to shout out
the Xbox the rumor is that yes like you
said you you nailed it like they were
working on that and whatever but the
rumor is this is not even the game no
that's not the game the Microsoft was
you know this is this is their baby this
is you know something that they was
trying to get done and trying to get out
the door that other game that Microsoft
was through the bag at them for that's
the game that a lot of these PlayStation
heads will not get that will be inside
game pass now I like I like how film
moves in these streets I mean let's
let's go to the political side we
already knows it's a great game sure I
like to go through metrics the metrics
close already told you follow those guys
they did get it right I went a little
bit higher with it on a metrics well
maybe if they like the graphics is a
little bit more polished then it would a
little bit higher on the metrics um but
let's go political with it mm-hmm now
we're gonna take care of our fan base
definitely and I'm not gonna exclude you
y'all can play at some point in time he
could have purchased the contracts and
in a daddy Joe but no he did that for
you you liked it and listen I want sure
to go on I want you to play and I want
y'all to purchase as much as possible
you know and all those game paths owners
y'all can go play and touch nice and
easy with no problems
it's freedom there for you mmm-hmm what
happens with the next one oh you gotta
work to happen next one how you gonna
feel about the next one you like this
one like it a lot like it a lot but it
don't have that game pastor you don't
have their Xbox you're just gonna like
it that's it and you're gonna like to
play that one again with Park to come
out unless you I got a bag up boy
that was that that is a point of
contention they lose on the rights well
we don't know because here's the thing
like is it like I want to get solving on
this a in minds like the content like
there seems to be a conflicting message
like at first we've seen certain things
and we were wise re over here why is
such such over there and then we we hear
from Greenberg and saying like no you
know these deals were in place
beforehand and now moving forward with
Xbox game studios you know that these
things will stay exclusive to Microsoft
so I guess the question people realize
once you make business deals like that
just because you're bought don't mean
they're changed like they have to honor
those those businesses so the question
is do we think that outer worlds too
will be exclusive I think I think Mac
Budi said as much right yeah me as taste
you get taste enjoyed the taste but you
know you paid for your taste like right
you know so but mmm dollars and cents
you paid $65 for a 1440p game if you
happen to be playing on a pro and we pay
me what 14 bucks 15 bucks and to be
playing it on X with the 4k most of
these games unless they're owned by
Microsoft they only get 30% of the
revenue so like I saw someone on a
Twitter say that it takes six games also
Don on PlayStation six games to sell on
on game paths then it does to equivalent
to one PlayStation 4 Coffee is like
first off they only get thirty percent
of the money and they don't they're not
even the publishers for acting like
they're the publisher they only get
thirty percent of the money that is in
that transaction they don't get the
whole $60 PlayStation gets that 30%
because they sold the you know all of
these market holders they get it they
get a cut of the pie wouldn't they sell
these games
no they said way to the next III Chris
the only reason why I'm wearing your
stuff I mean reading your stuff in the
chat which I don't do because it's not
the color but the only reason why I'm
reading your stuff is because you took a
severe beatdown on Twitter so Mesa City
joke on this let's stay with you I'm
gonna hold your hand throughout all this
process no no Chris I want I want
everybody to understand good gaming is
here right so chat for you yes couch
gaming
I'm Betty Vinita Phil for scooping
obsidian that's right and everybody
should everybody should applaud it
alright the Doretta brick should change
is it a good game in game past yep this
game past a place where old broken games
go nope is it a game that you spend $65
for and it's in game pads for free
yep and what's funny is in the past two
months this is a 285 plus games going
in-game pass and there's a lot more
indie games in there
but back to my feeling of the game yes
I'm going to play this game until till I
finish it I I've taken my time out on
doing missions i sat there and I
pondered my prayer I press pause I
pondered my decision is a big decision
that you got to make in the beginning
yeah I've pondered my decision and I
thought about it and I ate a sandwich
before I made the decision because I did
think about it and I was like man if I
do this this is dying this is gonna
dramatically change my experience going
home mm-hmm do this because I gotta play
this game again no and a different
experience a different choice so it's is
life-changing choices yes the point you
start saying gear yourself to be scary
yes have heart mm-hmm and if you if
you're looking at see in the beginning
what I do is I put all my stuff on
persuasia in the combo you'll be a
father to talk about this offline yeah
that's the same for my character my
lying is like 8080
yeah I can literally get like I don't
fight unless I have to
but these people know that yo if you
pick up right I will shoot you have any
of you uh yes I'm the dummy option we've
going over like the idiot my characters
not a dumbass so I don't have to do on
the like the highest difficulty or
something like that the dumbest oh I
don't think so I don't I think it's
available way anytime any plates
intellect has to be mad low before you
can yeah I would I don't know if it's on
the hardest difficulty you know I've
never had that option okay I will say
the King King definitely made a good
point because um again tough decisions
and because of either certain skill sets
unlocking new dialogue options right and
they were getting almost spoiled but
there was a very critical decision for
me early between groups and all I could
say is that like I was I was convinced I
was gonna go one way and then it combats
then I got there but then I like that
another conversation opened up and
because I had a perception skill didn't
opened up an extra dot and unlocked in a
tree and it would be a great area again
maybe a real great carrot when you when
you was in that last area about the you
know you coming close up to where you're
bouncing you know that you've got to
choose this did you did you think at any
time like is the whole time I was going
through that last section mmm-hmm the
whole time I was thinking I'm about to
piss someone off you know you know going
up to that big decision there was too
little minded decisions that you had to
make going yeah yeah because you talked
to one dude who had a real nasty opinion
of something then you came across that
something and you realize that it wasn't
what you said but and then it that
little something endeared itself to you
so you had to choose the Eva keep that
something alive or destroy and it's so
any options in so much to listen this is
meat and potato and I'm I haven't played
a long time all right I've only played
probably like five hours
god bless you um I put like 25 but the
it's turned into something that I
thought it was gonna be a shooter like
it's a Fallout and fallout has these
little dialogue trees too not to take
anything away from that fallout makes
you think about the characters and stuff
but they have done it so quickly into
the game that has snatched me in a game
then I'm I'm really paying attention to
what my side quest is and let me get the
super chat so now that's the kids move
the $2 to super chat diverting power
mission I changed my mind three super
set from Jay mo Scarlett the knees of
Sony fans day one like they make you you
know when you come across you come
across the first you know faction the
one you're originally doing this stuff
for shaggy slow mo out of jail talking
to this first fraction your alright you
know they want me to do and you meet the
second faction and then you start
learning stuff about the first pack
she's like yo it's that type of let me
get it - yeah yeah I gotta be high let's
kick it's not finished I'm sorry no I'm
just saying alright because I and this
is gonna divert a little bit from this
section right real quickly this isn't
this how Netflix started mmm
do you remember when Netflix all you can
get was just whack movies and then
because they got some movies that I want
to watch and then watch those movies and
then little by little they lie
very group yes and then they started
putting bangers in a little oh they got
movie okay and netflix started knowing
Netflix originals when you Netflix is on
such a roll right now with this Neff
originals they got this prank encounters
joined us out right now this is in it's
like a derivative of scare tactics I'm
into weird stuff like that but I'm
watching gaming past blossom mmm
I'm watching it grow from the land of
broken toys mm-hmm - this is a new
Ferrari mm dropped in a brand new
Lamborghini for you to drive so now the
rhetoric has to change this game when
I'm telling anybody has played it so far
mm-hmm they have switched their thoughts
in that little decision making a
beginning that will change a lot for you
and this is not something that's taken
lightly
so I'm saying now that you have great
games that's in there you know great
games is coming and this is not a great
game that they built for game pad is
both sides you can sympathize with why
it's just like man like these people
over here weirdos okay like but I know
what they do and it's like okay these
people over here they just trying to
survive it it's just like if I pick
these people is like is that the good
path or is that the bad path if I pick
like these people you kill them more
people but these people you kill unless
they just weren't they're not as bad and
that's the thing that gray area really
matters it's not it's not like a like
when you get great area in other games
like like are even Mass Effect like it's
not really it's still leaning more
towards one side of the other right it's
just a little bit more nuanced in the
decision but it's not really gonna give
you that true middle ground right here
you have all of that and in between and
the fact that they that's why I like the
fact that the game is smaller because
it's not it focuses on those
interactions and makes them real like
you wouldn't be a
have these interactions and these
decisions you make really matter as much
if this game was the size of a fall yeah
like that whole open world thousand
hours not everybody want out I'm glad
mojo said that earlier because that's
what I miss about this but let me jump
I'm ready
oh yeah yeah it's super chat let me get
in Justin Adams take your brother to our
super chat an obsidian game with a few
bugs is weird
loving it does that yeah I think I look
look first off for me playing on the X
um got it on SSD so loading is just
phenomenal I'm just like now and out
doing what I got to do um off top I will
say the first thing I noticed that I
love is the fact that it's a color
palette one of my things against the
wall out your favor your fall out kind
of game the nuclear fallout and I get it
it makes sense everything is trapped but
the green and the gray uh so when I get
out and you look at that skybox then
Atticus talk about and you see in the
planet and you seen you know I'm saying
it just feels vibrant it's that nice
difference I guess the space aspect
appeals to my Mass Effect side you know
I'm saying with the colonies and stuff
like that and you got to cooperation
stuff like that then obviously you got
the dialogue choices which is like epic
you know say and another thing I don't
think we give enough credit with the
dialogue is that I liked it when you
talking to somebody you could challenge
them like now what you get out of here
with like you can literally that the
responses to what you say to people that
the way those are written are hilarious
like you could be straight disrespectful
you know this I love I love that aspect
downloads great characters you care
about you know I'm saying combat I had
to get used to only because I'm a such a
vats guy and this really ate VAX this is
really like slow down and then pick your
shots or whatever whatever but the
companion joint is done really really
well cuz what I like is you can order
them to attack I got the home girl and
she's doing like a special wolves you
come down with like this old and hammer
thing and and it's like a cinematic
explosion when you have your companion
do that and you can level them up
they have their own perks and then you
can deal them up you know I'm saying so
I love love that aspect of it um for me
j-mo you see the switch get the chance
to experience it so he's a cog we'll be
jumping off all I say hey nobody jumping
off 4076 when we get to that topic but
it anyway
whoa no place ready for that nobody hit
it over here defend that look but what I
was gonna say is what I'm like again
just the high narrative solve just
characters you care about compelling
choices on humor so to me right now I
know everybody saying fall out and we
see in our massive it even got
Borderlands in it like it got like
there's a but it's just smarter humor
like Borderlands is very like toilet
humor like yeah yeah yeah look man I'm
really enjoying it and to King's point I
think that I think this is a really good
thing in a sense that look when Marcus
off acquired them obsidian right
everybody's like oh this is this is a
good move this is definitely everybody
felt strong about it and now to see the
high level of quality because again the
room were all game past is just fodder
oh you know I'm saying that kind of
thing to see a game of this stature of
this quality in game it feels like I'm
Chi it feel like I'm stealing when I'm
playing this endgame bad like that
couldn't see so many people the same
thing with gears like so now we've had
gears five high quality coalition on it
you know I'm sitting now I'm City and
comes back so boom and I'm saying
here comes you know out of worlds
high-quality like it gives you hope for
the future of game pass and the studio
acquisitions that if they continue this
quality it bodes well for their
long-term vision right it bodes well for
Microsoft and stuff like that so this is
cool and I got to get that dizzy right
guys he's in the chat
I think of Cydia got it right there boss
as far as the studio
right now I think of city is about mm
grow at the track record the DD and
listen go go they made it on a very low
budget yes this game has not been funded
my my my rusev it hit actually they
started this project as I think yeah
exactly crowdfunding and then private
division stepped in and you know gave
him some extra money to finish the game
but right for the most part it was not
funded by Microsoft even with the budget
this ad with the but so to me I imagine
what they can do that's what I'm saying
so it's like again is no disrespect to
ninja theory but let's not come on come
on come on I'm gonna get dizzy right now
Yatta you got it since then there's no
disrespect identity right hell-blade was
amazing we all liked hell-blade we
thought it was great
no saying but I didn't feel like I felt
like they started something that was a
new genre with the potential to be great
it was a very short game and it was on a
low budget and stuff like that and then
we got bleeding edge and bleeding edge
will see the jury is out now everybody's
screaming breathing but if you look
track record to track record with
obsidian versus that it's not even close
is that data up in common dudes
you know I'm say ninja Terry gotta
up-and-coming Microsoft Studios Citians
here [ __ ] is a young dude want to come
up they got a lot to prove it not
everybody's on the bleeding edge train
buddy so let's just get that out there
and we gotta see what's up what
hell-blade to and what's up with that we
need we're gonna do this obsidian
slander right now that's the gods right
continue but leading edges is just a
side project yeah we know sorry I
interviewed it the - out the way Chuck
there's no disrespect all I'm saying is
you know I'm just going to he's saying
it they the best thing we haven't
touched on are you gonna get that stitch
uh-oh like saddest into the two lattices
carved that move is called the filled
Dominus Hamlet
another thing that we haven't mentioned
besides that the craziness and the
options that you have in the dialog is
that when you specking your character in
a certain way really matters and it
makes you really like it besides Mass
Effect besides fallout
I got Deus Ex Vox there's Dave sects
depending on how you spec your character
you can play the game entirely that way
yes this game you know and they're not
real good about letting you know that
but this game if you spec your character
all the way to stealth mmm the way you
approach any type of engagement could be
completely different like if you really
think about trying to hack into a place
or I'm like just enter a place you're
not supposed to you have a lot of
options to do that and obviously you
have to be Specht in that in that
direction but the options had opened up
for you to do that are honestly you can
play the game completely differently to
what you would expect you be able to
play it at and that's not something in
that they've really getting out there
insane that's another amazing thing
besides this variation in dialogue
option there makes this the game kind of
infinitely replayable and that the fact
that it's a shorter game that's what you
want to do right and the fact that these
like all the way you see a scenario can
play our completely different every time
you play is kind of crazy just talk
about addict in a couple people shot the
range virus one Twitter you know a lot
of people played that same situation and
I'm hearing things that I didn't even
know was possible could happen in that
same scenario mm-hmm it's just it's so
well written man again I got I got dizzy
bag I love it he put the buddy of the
chat let's go he's safe am he said no
one stepped in to help
ninja Terry they didn't put it in a chat
put it says does he come up with a cage
coming for the cake of a car
yo whoever they may who take obsidian is
the the number one studio put number one
and if you think ninja Theory's the
number one xbox games do you put number
two because that's fitting for them they
have a sword and they have a seat let em
see hey Bobby you coming back with a
show next week for that double one thank
you brother
Oh demon you traitor
David first of all you should get about
it the geeky there Bobby well alright
now we go game apart let's go go let
dizzy we want DC's knees y'all this is
for Dizzy's knees as much as we're dizzy
going at it you know this is fun to see
like King said just as quality of stuff
studio King how dare you who do you
think is the best you shut out of those
two percent yeah obsidian versus digital
let's get it let's get to not even close
okay so you got digit a right it's not
even close it's not even close it's not
even close if you just go by pedigree
like anything is I loved into theory I
and I hope they have to get the budget
and the backing to do some amazing stuff
but the pedigree of obsidian graphical
bliss always brings to the table action
listen check it out check it out just
graphically justice let's just take it
real quickly nonetheless not unless you
don't have to go through anything else
just put them side by side right and say
who had the bigger budget and you will
look at him and say oh definitely
Oh minja theory games had a bigger
budget no they had the smaller budget
and he made bigger things now when they
have a budget that he's equal comparable
to each other hold on don't read that
super check
[Laughter]
[Music]
because both are in pocket it's a fun
internal battle for Xbox 50 know you
know you know what's good bean I'm not
gonna have this conversation yeah you
said me what's better three three or
[Music]
nobody nobody talks about it don't you
fine it's nice it's great
hey they have studios now yeah that you
sitting here talking about they have
studio and and and this is the even
better part those games come date and
day you know it about you know what
really makes me happy is the fact that
they it's they literally have like three
Studios now that's going to be making
RPG games yes because the obsidian is
won an exam which obviously they are
working on new studios exactly so you've
got three studios are going to be
working on quality RP seems like that's
gonna be the focus of their studios
right they sort of have the Western RPG
market kind of cornered and then you
gotta you gotta consider they're still
making the halos the gears of forces we
don't know what coalition's do don't
know what compulsion I mean we don't
really don't know what ninja theories
doing we don't know what um what that
one new studio is gonna do after
Psychonauts is released so it's nice to
be on the Xbox platform not knowing
anything why you might be onto something
to our stupid chef my man you're
definitely right
I do believe that I'm onto something you
know say it Israel we got a move oh man
we got to fly to these last time we can
get about it um it's actually upon me
I'll make this quick
um yes no dropped it's actually no it's
not on me I apologize this is attic
attic we gotta get you in it
attic this is on you right now some news
drop for last of us a little over a
month ago
mmm they did a stay to play Sony did and
they announced the Last of Us whose
release date I guess something got lost
in the mail maybe they maybe they forgot
the you know that those movies were
someone calls to stop an execution at
the last minute maybe that didn't happen
but for some reason the games been
delayed three months when last month
they were sure about a date right so
what I want to bring to the table to the
Lord's to talk to the realm first off is
this an issue no is this an issue about
being delayed in general and second off
do you think Sony knew that this game
was not coming out in February months
ago I'm doing attic space Havana had his
camera oh man last of us to delayed are
you surprised where are you at with this
man not surprised at all and I do
believe something new is gonna be late
they just drop that nugget to grab some
attention and they do things like that
hey it's business but it's not gonna
affect their sales and all it's still
coming out for this djinns games but it
gets it a little closer than ps5 so you
can get that immediate patch to gain him
that'll be you know even more amazing
and it will help push that piece
ourselves so I know what they're doing
and they knew real quick cuz I know
trying to get out of here but I wanna go
back to that game pass people are like
all these up Microsoft games people
don't think this is gonna blow up
it's not understanding the math so
here's math 101 brakes only dropped two
games a year six dollars each they're
bangers 10 million sales Tom 64 a year I
was at one point three billion dollars
not it's all the money cost of the
remedy studios make the games blah blah
blah seven eight hundred million then
you got to give some of that profit also
advertising all that comes out of it but
we'll just leave it at about seven eight
hundred million
okay Microsoft is gonna get to thirty
million that's their goal on game pass
thirty million ten to fifteen dollars a
month a month
suppose a super easy honey two or three
billion they're gonna make triple the
amount of money people don't think
they're gonna get to thirty million
they're crazy
anybody always subscribe to live and
they gave that sixty dollars a year
they're now given 120 dollars a year to
have all these games I'm just telling
you let's see what you and that hoping
about how Netflix grew grew grew and
then blew up to learn numbers and
they'll have 35 36 million 33 million
cuz they're gonna lose people each month
gain people but they're gonna get enough
over 30 min so that's always our minimum
fair enough I see the lone play more
than that I don't know but I do know
that that is there some real quick you
know what the outer world does you know
like says and I xbox live what you're
playing again it apparently certain
sections of outer worlds it says the
outer world is exploring and then it
says the parentheses read a copy or yeah
touches on that game was just for crazy
let's get mods @mods man um last of us
to delayed you know the drunkness
statement everything that you heard
what's your thought process of this ah
well I don't think it's going to hurt
anyone and stuff and I guess I I'm not
going to say that oh it's bad I mean
like I guess it's better if they need
some extra time to develop the game and
pull you the game stuff right right but
a DNA one more delay and it's going to
become a PlayStation 5 lunch title yeah
yeah I mean like you know I don't mind
because like I don't mind waiting for
good games and I'm sure I'm sure that
last of us is going to be a great game
so and there's going to be a lot of
games to play
you know February March anyway so you
know an April Simon absolutely no doubt
man I'm soft where you at with this man
the delay of your beloved single player
okay like you know they do need to
polish the game up more it's just weird
cuz you you wouldn't know a month a
month out like you're gonna tell me the
game got that much bigger you like you
didn't you weren't able to see how much
work needed to be done and a month later
is when you forget it just doesn't make
any sense so I agree wit I grew with
mojo de they knew and for whatever
reason I just wanted to get the word out
they felt that you know people
complaining they hadn't heard anything
about last of us but it on on Twitter
it's like look we got two to nine months
to a death strikes people something to
talk about something to talk about and I
got that it's like the biggest thing
that I'm confused with that I just don't
understand
would we when we we have known if Jason
Charlie so it makes even less sense like
why not just give that may date from the
jump
they wouldn't wouldn't be surprising to
people let me go ahead and sit before I
state this okay I put that coming out of
me
the record glass so I could without
color for this one so couch gave you
said beachy should drop me so bad I mean
and that's another thing if anybody that
thinks that this is delayed to add the
multiplayer that didn't happen that's
not happening so that you there's no way
you're adding multiplayer in a couple of
months especially as big as they they
claim it's gonna be or whatever it's a
song thing so yeah that's not it
and like matt said like one more delay
and it's a ps5 launch title much like I
believe ghost of Tsushima will be
and that is another game that is rumored
to be pushed to late 2020 mm-hmm Jason
Strayer pretty much said that you know
he believed is going to be like 2020
game I mean goes off to see Marvis yeah
yeah that's beer so King man you've been
chuckling so what's going on
Lord last of us to delay what was your
thoughts when you heard the news when is
the June or May because that's what am I
gonna for quality Gabe oh [ __ ] back
white well then wait you gonna buy it on
PlayStation 5 and listen they don't have
no games coming for the PlayStation 5 so
all those old games that you're gonna
get you're gonna get it then and it's
not gonna be no patch okay cuz you're
not gonna take a PlayStation 4 game and
put it in there it's not gonna be no
patch there's gonna be a PlayStation 5
game mm-hmm that's gonna have the
enhanced qualities that you're gonna pay
that extra bucks to all right and it's
not gonna be the same price as the
PlayStation 4 game it's gonna be a
praise agent five nice price all right
so you're gonna get your game your city
that happens that means you have saws
nice oh yeah listen solve solve knows
already there's no backup at in there
when they made it official most games
won't be back to pet who is this you
wanna tell me you ain't read it why
there was a there was a Japanese was a
clip or something again saying most
games won't be back compare it's very
hard to determine because it was it was
like the translation was take the war
when it comes out and I want you to
throw it inside and see if you don't
break your pinky
okay enough little no for the rhetoric
your knees will be shipped over here I'm
not even worried about it they not doing
it rotating on that statue much I need
to be made so what this dis delay does
it affect them no PlayStation who's
gonna sit down they gonna take it why
because they said I've heard this too
much
Oh for good doing cuz you know it's
gonna be quality I'm anticipating it
further now that they pushed it they not
doing nothing to the game the game was
done shut down no I'm what would he
doing right now I'm fixing a little AI
bugs
okay cleaning up bugs in the game
they're painting the game any further
from what it was when you saw when he
did that deep dive into the game no big
that much of a deep dive into that game
that gave me a change it to much more
from what it is they're not no
multiplayer so get your hopes out of it
they not want anything else and they're
not shining it up they know it's already
done
they're making you wait for financial
purposes nothing to do it the deal
druckmann statement about meeting ball
pilots go this is a skate completely
done you go to the king oh no how do you
not see this polish a month ago yeah no
it's not that man it's everything to do
it positioning there the weird thing is
also is that it pushes them if it's me
right I said it is me right doesn't it
push them out of this fiscal year yeah
you know why they're doing that
no it's someone PlayStation view they
trying to sell and now you mean now what
is gold views the TV thing yeah they're
so hmm so back when I told y'all before
financially these dudes are in trouble
this is like man that really but then
they selling off a portion of their
house if you come to somebody's house
and their bathroom is being sold to the
highest bidder
something's up listen keep watching the
view keep watch oh you can't watch the
view no more cause being so little
pieces of they hand disappear all right
for your last of us - because it's -
y'all wait hell why the disrespect today
I'll jump in real quick bad um as far as
the delays it was just a crazy week we
had that we had Ubisoft as well you ever
said we had um you know the division I'm
saying it wasn't doing well and then
goes we can't break point so you know
Ubisoft in a whole nother place right
now but with Last of Us I'm going to add
it did surprise me because it's like
we're not a month removed from the
announcement of the release date so I
was a little surprised at that point you
know how you how you call you how you
not sure of when you know this thing is
gonna be finished so that's my only
concern
delay is good at the end of the day get
it right polish it up do what you got to
do I'm not mad at the delay I'm just
confused at the timing the QuickTime
after you just announced a release date
I've never seen that before I've never
seen like a a game on both whatever is
it the new dude in charge
oh I think Naughty Dog that they have
autonomy in that like just anybody you
like sort of run wild and do what they
just need to do is not it was sorry oh I
hear what you say and Naughty Dog has
that cache and they've delayed games
before I'm not always they're always
delayed all I'm saying is I've never
seen the like with the state of play the
media hype the the you know you're
getting galvanizing the base you give us
a date everybody and then not even it
has it been a full months
like it month yeah it feels so short to
come back and say yo you know Neil
druckmann coming up comes out with a
statement you know we're not gonna make
it
again um I don't know what's going on in
there right oh it just feels weird right
it just feels like maybe are they under
pressure is the fact that PlayStation 5
looming you know I'm saying we already
know they're not putting the multi
player as part of this right so I just I
just concerned that I hope there's no
internal it'll be room oh my god I am
NOT a developer I don't know and I think
yeah yeah I hear what you think about
you know quietly something there being
some weird strife because not open let
me get this the gamer by choice with the
$20 super check weights no King you got
me rolling here I just yesterday I saw
that a dev left naughty I was just about
to get to it's all that and the way he
said it was kind of like it again it was
like quitting he was quitting because he
was he was not happy with something it
was like studio charlatan Cooper I want
to shout out anger man I want to shout
out to a couple brought it to my
attention again I am NOT trying to say
there's definitely stuff going on I'm
just gonna report on what I got there
all I'm saying is we got a release date
a month out now of a certain the release
dates change then we hear from Jonathan
Cooper who I believe was like this lead
animator he came from the assassin creed
three days you know I'm saying and he
jumped on and then he makes a Twitter
statement and this was on the 26 so this
is just yesterday I've decided to part
ways with Naughty Dog I'm thankful to
have contributed to the ps4 era of the
story studios and I wished him luck in
their future endeavors
so he's leaving again is there a
correlation I don't know he's bring it
back to me yeah swinging please continue
these dudes just downplaying everything
that's going on
really they said okay the games coming
out this time we're all good everything
ready to rock they had a big press
conference and then they come out later
on some little loose you know basically
this kind of be three months later okay
and then if you quit listen man at what
point in time well y'all gonna start to
understand this real problems going
alright but what about what about studio
Dead's leave everyday be what about the
same energy but when the halo joint
everybody was like nah Studios move
every baby remember that we use on our
camera now we do it didn't I keep that
same energy didn't I say this I'm wrong
with that yeah yeah but but energy here
too cuz I still never he's over this
Jonathan Cooper guy yeah yeah he was the
lead a he's a lead animator I told you I
thought was a lead animator because I
was like I saw he was an animator and he
had like 20,000 followers I was like
he's gotta be the lead animator no one
has that many followers do you write
lead or something you're not he's got he
also worked on Mass Effect uncharted 4 I
mean this guy's pedigree you know is a
Miller statement again his tweet again
his tweet exactly I've decided to part
ways with Naughty Dog
so he's like no but he said what what
else he said I'm thankful to have
contributed to the ps4 era of this
storage studio and I wish them luck in
their future endeavors like it do feel
like your arm out feel like yeah like a
new feel weird it looks like it looks
like that thing that's like I got it
respectful because I'm looking for
another job when I'm Ryan would they say
yeah like it's a we got a paper real
quick go for it got a photo super try
from Brad mmm-hmm no internal dev issue
purse someone who was there that's what
I heard hashtag nugget I mean listen no
sources
[Laughter]
like her you know when I heard King will
be the best game ever made you know
that's what I heard going down in flames
we don't know what's going on none of us
are inside there we don't know but you
did raise the flag moon is the flag go
up oh wow the whole crew we go see what
happens we you know it is definitely an
interesting situation we got to pay
attention with last of us you know what
its release date will eventually be if
it hits you know the targets we'll see
but we got two more we go just combine
because we got to move on it's
definitely long show um I'm gonna jump
miles quick on PlayStation 5 you know
I'm saying so uh pretty much there was
some hiring some job postings you know
and shout the dealer gave me as a
fantastic video out on this as well
about being the fastest consul and um I
want to bring that connect up first I
gotta bring mods first I gotta bring
miles for God really okay I'll let it go
so my question to the realm you know
obviously you know since then the job
listing has been taken down initially
the job listing had stated you will be I
guess the position was some type of a
cloud engineer senior cloud engineering
manager at PlayStation Sony interactive
and then it pretty much withstanding
that you will be working on the next
generation you know I'm saying
PlayStation 5 and that's what it says
you know
we'll be one of the leaders in only two
le team super excited to launch the
upcoming world's fastest console in 2020
the PS 5 since then the posting has been
amended that section about the fastest
console is no longer there
so I want to bring it to the ration of
cake I wanna bring it to the robe but
you sent me over
do we think because of this verbage that
the playstation 5 will be the most
powerful console and that this is all I
want to know why so much soda slander
today from PR team but can we get some
balance ISM some levity but what do you
do about this listing that has since
been amended I mean obviously it's an
interesting one because like like
actually when I saw it I like literally
seconds after I tweeted it out and say
saying basically so it's going to be the
fastest console but doesn't mean that
it's going to be more powerful most
powerful because like you know
and obviously the real question is in
terms of speed what the hell are they
referring to is that going to be the
fastest SSD is that the fastest fun is
that probably super fast you know but
like me like we don't know and you know
and but it's actually interesting that
actually both Microsoft and Sony are
actually focusing more on speed
performance faster load times rather
than graphics right and I think you know
this is where the next generation is
going to be kind of this is where the
the next gen console wars is going to be
in focusing on I mean that the
performance and that can start right
right although interestingly enough I've
heard some rumors coming from I think
his name is like bits and pieces or
something like that bits and whatever
right chips
he's actually a PC kind of leaker and he
said that he heard that both PlayStation
5 and and next Xbox going to have well
very similar if not identical CPUs right
let me let me stop you for a second cuz
I got I think I want to be play devil's
advocate and let's just say
theoretically when the posting went up
right that let's say I mean let's let's
keep it real like we won with fake that
you know Microsoft or Sony they have a
lot of connections they have a lot of
people who deal on both sides that
sometimes some of them may know certain
things aspects about the other one for
the hardware standpoint so let's just
say whatever this metric that they're
utilizing whether it be the SSD or
according to my fan speed you know they
like you know what if there is one
aspect that they kind of have pegged as
a superior part of the PlayStation we're
gonna get to that but my question of Maz
is do you think there is a possibility
that there is one aspect of the
PlayStation 5 that may be faster and
maybe they're using that terminology or
do you just mean do you it but do you be
faster beings more powerful how
you interpret that I mean yeah I think
it they are referring to one particular
aspect of the consult because like at
the end of the day I mean look at the
PlayStation 4 and Xbox one for example
right you could argue that place they
that Xbox one original Xbox one has a
faster CPU because it does it runs at
one point seven five one point six so
who knows my maybe PlayStation 5 might
may have like a slightly faster CPU or
you know I don't know faster rap who who
knows right so but I think they are
referring to one particular thing you
think about the proprietary SSD are they
working on could be but like Microsoft
is going to have their own version of it
anyway I mean like I was even listening
to the you know Xbox 2 podcast with
Rondo foreign and jazz he was actually
by basically saying that even I don't he
doesn't even believe that those
developers I have kids around yeah they
don't believe me I mean and I believe in
because like right now if anything those
like final chips the final SOC chips
they probably going to be ready like
early next year
mm-hmm because that's when the final
silicon and this is when they will know
this the clock speeds and that can stop
because I don't think they even now know
what kind of clock speeds they're going
to be dealing with because you know they
haven't retested it properly right I
mean they've got prototypes and stuff
but right you know sorry so laws like
you give me ten seconds work we need to
catch up on some sushi okay so got it
we got a 10 ounce of chat from paxil bit
G these sony changed that listening
being they know they are fronting
really sit because they just threw that
out to hamper gears 5mm hash tag PS /
play dirty they play dirty yeah that's a
lot shout-out to a brat with the five
dollar super chat Playstations next
monster will be PlayStation 5 is the
bestest hello
oh my god a bit up we got shroom kingdom
and drunken ninja sauce you want to get
those I sat at the drunken Indian with
the $2 to beat at every time you load up
PS now thank Microsoft the only council
with the square card reader the dealer
Gaming Freud Neto how far did you get in
out of worlds main menu I got far man I
made a big planetary decision he coming
for me and I'm playing games I'm a beat
out of worlds to prove kognito please
you know you notice every time this man
makes a character like he looks
identical things using him as a template
[Laughter]
let's get let's get real quick mojo man
what do you think man this this whole
thing with the job advertisement is just
silly that's got nothing to do with what
it's gonna be that's somebody in HR put
that out and they gotta call quick to
change it cuz they don't know what
Microsoft's is because I also believe
there is no scarlet dev kits out yet
they've only got like spec sheets saying
hey write your PC at this level working
on these games and then dev kits will be
coming later mm-hmm no doubt and and I
think the original you know little blurb
in that job announcements probably was
about SSDs but even that they can't know
for sure right so you think it marketing
marketing speak is where you're leaning
towards yeah but I don't even get
smartening I think that's a job posting
so that was like somebody in a jar
you know maybe they picked up a phone
and called marketing hey we're posting
this what can we say about it I don't
know I don't work for something but yeah
they're on fire you start talking change
job got a joke quick this off okay what
you think about this all day okay so
let's get that super chair first from
yes yes case move any of y'all botched a
mission yet in the outer world question
to the panel anybody's watch it is an
option like if you look at your hotel
you it'll tell you if you messed up on a
mission all right I'll do that check
police stations marketing ps5 swipe your
credit card just clean it up you know
like the Barry Bonds he is alright so I
watched a Liz video right until it was
on to something when he said you know
faster is equating to more powerful
that's how he views it he views if
somebody can get the information home
faster then that makes the system more
powerful and is a terminology inbox and
you know speed equates power alright so
when I saw the rallying cry I read it I
read it a couple of times and it felt
like a rallying cry it felt like you
know job listing to get you fired up
when you're coming into the job you know
you're ready to go you so you get in you
hit the ground running that's what it
seemed like to me because it said stuff
like you know people with a passion they
want to be here they want to work here
and you know Playstation and and felt
really like howdy-do in the background
when they get you geared up and you're
ready right before we go to watch you
know fans nice and stuff like that they
do us they give us a rally we all
fevered up we all lathered up we get out
there all screaming like so yeah the
chance to be I mean one of these little
mission statements and stuff like that
this would have sound like now I did not
know that it got stricken da today yeah
that's very telling because it's telling
in the Saints of you're not confident in
your wording get that word yeah I agree
it's one of those things like why not
leave it if you're confident right
remember y'all had the most powerful
system before until Phil says stop that
noise like shut your mouth you can't run
with that then your talk about dynamic
for cake okay now you got to change your
wording around you I don't want to be
caught with your pants down tomorrow
alright so you making a statement
whoever the individual was
pretty sure that he was reprimanded well
alright don't put that in there again
you know just give you a little rally
and statement get people here let this
job post and go up let these people come
to work all right but you're working for
second best to be honest with you
because right now
Microsoft is putting a foot forward and
let me tell you why you know that you
working for second best because you're
not confident in your wording just y'all
have been doing Microsoft put out one
word and they put something back miss
messaging y'all sitting here talking
about myself don't know if they coming
up going you wrote it looks like Sony's
taking the same motto was but then he
didn't know what it was they was the
fastest but then they not sure you know
what if this thing is no Russians y'all
know all they go they keep it receipts
for if this thing comes out to be more
powerful I'm just saying I want the
energy to be the same that's why that's
why you know it is like Microsoft State
there's been two comments here and there
no outright statement from the Xbox
brand as well as one as a unified
statement like with top because with
Scorpia was announced they definitively
said most powerful console will not the
Scarlett vision it we did not hear the
same garbage the spec sheets on old boy
remember the last time yes last time
Sony at the last minute switched every
mm-hmm at the last minute they switched
a memory in a PlayStation 4 mm-hmm yes
gonna go with one one type of memory
they will with the faster memory and the
last second mm-hmm the ddr5 about ADR
yeah pants down this time it's a
different dude in charge so I'll have to
get in line you have to take those
little word
faster you know who you are is really
upon your head systems is out and mark
my word Microsoft is coming out first
mmm coming up December they're not
moving in November they not move a name
November date November I think that
December is a placeholder King I don't
know so nee yeah right now as as how
they move in now reference to release
date please I heard you chirping good
buds yeah yeah I mean like actually I
wanted to actually add something to the
whole PlayStation 5 man Xbox cover thing
I mean in terms of release date like
there's been some rumors about December
5th place issue 5 something so yeah that
would be actually interesting and I
don't although there's been like do
leaks in about it so but I still think
it's going to be like November for both
consoles yeah yeah but I wanted add
something to the whole Xbox color versus
PlayStation 5 power and everything right
I mean we all need to remember that Phil
Spencer right has already said that the
very same SOC so very very same chips
that are going to be installed in xbox
Carl it's going to be used for as your
so going to be actually use not only for
game streaming but also for professional
workloads
right and the thing is that you know
with with that kind of chips they have
to be super power efficient and
everything right right so I'm kind of
like leaning towards the fact that you
know whatever Microsoft and even the
wording that AMD's working is actually
using for like you know the whole
Microsoft partnership isn't they said
something like they Co Co engineered
yeah they hold so it's not necessarily
like oh we made this chip for Microsoft
right
we kind of like made it like together
right like a joint Yakko engineering
verbage yes they actually using totally
different like wording as with regards
to like playstation 5 warning right so I
mean like this like makes me to believe
that you know there they can actually
get away with like more powerful and
bigger chip because they're going to be
like ordering the these chips in like
you know I don't know maybe like in tens
of millions because they're not going to
be only using it for scholar what you're
saying is because Microsoft has more
money they can have a better chip yeah
money is not everything the fact alone
that the very same chips going to be
used not only for gaming but also for a
flash pro or professional news like may
I and that kind stuff right it that
makes me believe that these let's say
that these chips should be special right
mm-hm
so you're saying Sony chips are less
special oh we gotta see how this thing
play it is very interesting you know who
knows what's gonna happen I can't agree
with you guys I was a little my eyebrow
went up when it went down when the the
job listing that part of the job listing
went down to me it shows that Sony wants
to back away from that you know I'm
saying right at this point I still think
there are things to be determined that
both sides yeah we don't know but in my
opinion fastest doesn't necessarily
equate to most powerful yes yet we need
more information so it could be just one
ask me that's all I got King let's not
the sting up man
fallout 76 do any diva say anything
anymore this one yes yes we do time
let's play a game
resolve your entire issues with this
statement in 40 seconds
check it out is the game right this is
how not to do a streaming service
fallout 76 first dish
a hundred dollars to get you something
that you should have got in the
beginning they promised some private
service which it can't be private
service because once you go offline yeah
your world is not progressive it doesn't
keep going while you're gone
actually your world shirts off and all
you're doing is having your friends come
over it's like a sleepover circle
they're charging you a hundred dollars
for the game you don't want to buy $60
for it I want to know is we need them
I'll jump in real quick man look this
game is the gift that just keep on
giving the foolish it's just to the
point now it's just like look I don't
even like talk about it no more because
it's like what more wrong can they do to
sullied a name all right like every
every week is the new bunk it's a new
thing to Sully and it's just like look
here's a day you know we know about the
launch we know about the glitches the
bugs all the problems you know at this
point I don't know anyone that's going
to subscribe to this you know they like
especially now we got out of worlds
moving and a lot of people really feel
this is direction they should be the
thing I have the problem I got with them
solved is a king we just came from e3
right
they just ingest that's what I'm saying
like go Brody we just went to e3 we went
to the Bethesda conference the Lords
were there and I sat that I said you
know what this was a good meal Copa
right Todd how it came on with the same
jacket say what you had to say cuz there
and you know we sorry and you know what
up cold Mia culpa it do it right then
they drop the low pneumos they had the
low on free content or whatever the
battle royal I thought it'd look cool
all right you know what maybe they can
come back and then you know we got bad
game canvas baggy and then we got
statues making people sick and all this
type of stuff and now we come on but but
there's the what what is going on with
marketing with PR what's going on like
this is her I've never seen a studio
with this much cash a like prior to 76
Podesta with them dudes right
like renowned revered you could never
say anything about them and now it's
literally the butt of every joke you
know I'm saying
and there's 76 again I don't know what
market this is for I don't know who is
running out there with the hundred
dollar premium private server and we
know it's the sad part song they had the
nerve to ask fans what are things you
want from fallout 76 then we can improve
[Laughter]
it this is not it they really need a
sit-down or talking to a lashing
somebody gotta get somebody gotta go on
corporation to redact this whole game no
shout out the dizzy they delayed the
free stuff the problem but there is the
is the Washington Redskins brought this
is yo I mean take a minute bro I'm
trying to defend your people like I
don't know whose child Disney two-dollar
super chair who's worth now but that's
the implicit they are battling for the
worst reputation now India it's really
scary up that starfield so people forget
about this cuz they may be your shelter
know much they need to make it
free-to-play dethroning game but they
need to something like you don't play a
different game path I know you
[Laughter]
everybody else was jumping on this
fallout what I worry about
yeah I know you know they see Todd
Howard said as much that you know the
starfield and the next eldest growth is
gonna be what you expect but I don't
know that I believe that a hundred
percent like cuz this thing the tickets
they came out they acknowledge they came
out like they did with fallout 4 it's
like they may need that game in a hole
without sticking their head up and
seeing what the rest of the world was
doing did you drop this game Norfolk was
gonna have issues
but known for well they're games out
there that follow a similar path in
terms of monetization and stuff you
could you could gain you could look at
other things and see where the mistakes
were made and try not to make those
mistakes which they didn't do with this
it just felt like you said like at e3 he
came out and acknowledged all of it if
felt great but at least it was a them at
least coming out because most companies
won't come out to the forefront and say
hey we messed up you know as stays as it
looked with the stupid little video of
showing all the people playing but
whatever but at least and then you come
out and you do not it's not what we're
trying to do
to give people features that should have
been in the game from the beginning to
make it feel like a complete game you
have people like I realized that a lot
of stories that came out of fallout 76
that people were like you know they were
really role-playing and playing these
roles in the world and helping people
out they started and that's cool in it
of itself but let's not remember let's
remember that came out of the fact that
there wasn't enough game there to for
people to do so exactly that was seen
with the one else which I shot the brat
fire on us which I Podesta is in the
bushes internally heard this is Ana
popular decision with everyone there
continues oh yeah it's just like to me
it worries me about their thinking
moving forward you know cuz even if I
lack thereof because even then if star
field comes out or if Elder Scrolls six
comes out and it's still more of the
same without addressing even the older
issues they always have it they have
problems with but this is when you look
at like I said I it feels like Microsoft
has kind of cornered the market with
some great Western RPG developers but
that's the better look out they better
look out because not everybody cares
about you know two hundred plus our RPGs
oh we didn't mean they need they need to
straighten this out either either kill
this and make it free-to-play and
definitely don't utilize this thinking
and when it comes to their core RPGs so
one question do you think they did this
right before it goes to free-to-play
I want I would hope so I would hope so
but then even that is weird I mean I
don't know hey if they do that that
would look even worse because it's like
you're trying to get as many idiots on
board I mean think about it even like
when you look at a stadium with the
death with destiny - it's like hmm
alright you're making me pay $129 if you
want me to play upfront right with his
dumb controller that doesn't connect
it's kind of spooky man Casper quit this
thing that could draw 576 they stole a
bunch assets from fallout 4 they gotta
bring in so much money have a big game
so that's what we got
this year they still don't have a big
game this is their cash grab your
playback once you've done this that's
another thing that is interesting that
on the mold you'll mention like they
don't have a big game this year yeah
yeah yeah we got to see I mean yeah it's
crazy to see how the mighty have fallen
you know hopefully they can get it
together man but we got to get up out of
here
new I LP Paul with the recent release
and positive reviews received by
obsidian and outer worlds in game Pass
does this give you more confidence in
the quality of gay paths as a service
moving forward the choices are a no game
Paz is mostly fire in quality wait until
the
Cillian releases a game exclusively
under the Microsoft banner B yes gamepad
still provides great value and proves
that phil was on to something for next
gen C I don't care don't shave me for
pay $60 per game that is the question
those are the choices please rock the
boat when it goes up on the ILP Twitter
Lord mojo blues and Lord mods in the
realm holding us down next-gen podcast
Lord mojo tremendous history to many
stories where can the fine people find
you and what do you have going on sir
mostly on Twitter mojo underscore blues
one you know I'm there a lot cuz of the
overnight working thing my youtube
channel is the same mojo underscore
blues one not a lot of content on there
but there's some 20 30 minute rants and
stuff I've been told people kind of like
it when I do that stuff but I've got
stuff coming I've been saying this for
months but life keeps making me push it
back I'm gonna have game reviews I'm
gonna have movie reviews I'm gonna have
my little milkshake show with with
moving movie talk not reviews on that
though though it's gonna get good and of
course I'm on Maja's next-gen podcast
with a wonderful give me Moran it's like
Mads brings the facts yes sir Jamie
keeps everything level and I get about
games and it's it's good nice bass
battles honored to be part of that show
or the first episode my mistake what are
the first what the early ones yeah yeah
Mars they're coming in the round so
Lunas are Lords of gaming dotnet tech
guru as well as the next gen podcast
host where can I find behind you what do
you have going on sir yeah I mean like
obviously mods gaming YouTube channel
mods gaming PL at Twitter
well next gen podcast every Wednesday
usually unless something happens that we
to do it on Thursday yeah thanks a lot
for the invite love the show all of your
guys energy and stuff
I've got some stuff coming for loads of
game I was playing something this week
but I was like super busy and family
stuff and yes
thanks a lot then the yeah and picked up
like button guys and surely you know
much love man llamas always a pleasure
to have you in the room and really
appreciate what you do everything for us
in there oh shout out to the video yeah
I said he had a the son one I thought he
had to said he was making faces I
thought it was the little boy he's a
proper Xbox father he loves oh the one
bad mother the final super chad great
show great chat get the word out so
millions I know that no perfect segue to
our man Lord anak wicked afar people
find you what you got going on sir
he's in the bushes all the way returning
back great to have you wicked if I do
friends what you got going on and
download our big shout out to mojo for
coming through I mean from our era
always love to have that on the show
that's that's a turd love right now my
heart right there and of course Lord
mods for coming to thank you guys for
being here really appreciate it
um you know you guys can find me I'm
Laura Saba LP on Twitter and you're BX
sovereign at PSN and xbox live one other
thing I know the guys mentioned it last
week um guys our friend and brother Lord
Izzy needs our help
yes needs our help battling this a whole
that we call cancer yeah
f cancer guys so I'm gonna gonna put it
in the in the chest and it's gonna be in
the show notes again and it'll be on the
show notes at Lord gave me that net as
well this link to the his family's
GoFundMe I don't actually I don't
okay I don't know if you know I went
through um guys definitely Lord is he
needs our help
absolutely he's a pregnant brother and
this makes you out there in support yes
it real quick again like I said earlier
recent news also again we try to keep
tabs on all our brothers in the gaming
community
Lourdes Italian clans on ground yeah
he's he's about to have a heart
procedure please send some positive
vibes some thoughts his ways good dude
man we've had them on I'll pee a few
times
we always got love for four guys of
quarters and yeah man please me what I
said some positive vibes his way so if
you see him on Twitter suit um a message
shoot him a DM you know I'm saying let's
hope he gets through that procedure Lord
King up in the realm firing shots in
everywhere not believing Saudi or a lot
of figs we're gonna father Sony don't
believe Sony shout out the mojo mojo is
the true importer yeah he was there
literally getting this stuff important
firsthand like he made it you got it
right there that's what's up I love the
story I love the backstory I love your
service to this country thank you sir I
do appreciate you and everything that
you do I appreciate the fact that you
got on a Pokemon shirt right now so yes
I appreciate the fact that you are still
gaming no matter what I will tune in I'm
so happy that I met you right now so
this is Captain prompt I don't know what
and--okay is but we like the country
it's a luat okay with them $40 salut
bruh please say something please let
your words be $40 exam and much
appreciated sir katika okay so you can
catch me on twitter king david OTW
and I won't try to get to that teespring
stuff no put on this shirt it's the
Norwegian cross shoutout to go doorway
in a house that's was a big dig so we
put this shirt on make sure that y'all
making it happen
figure out who can partner with to get
some actual fitted something so also
listen man see that Hawk back there man
to load the game it down net make sure
you can look at the all or King Kos
statues Kingdom statues make sure you
get over there check that stuff out and
also you heard Mars modulus told you
that he's about to put up a piece on
loads of game of that night please go
over there check out all the information
if you if you like anything my says and
mods is terribly tough technical alright
he will definitely tell you exactly
what's the inner he was told by SOC and
all this other stuff and he breaks it
down to you in a way that you can
understand it please get there follow
like follow subscribe make sure that you
read and listen and watch all these
videos that's there is more than just
what you see here is a whole bunch of
stuff there alright L and C cargas he he
he is so modest he's so modest he's not
gonna tell you he's not gonna pump up
the last word I'm a pump up the last
word bro alright so anytime I need to
know something about what's going on a
destiny is talking about something in
destiny I have to sometimes I have to
shut these dudes all right over there
look at the last word and umm roundtable
reviews is up with the Joker right now
from um you know shot the meds meds I
might solve and carbide soo they're
gonna give you a great take on that
movie if you haven't sword if you saw it
um please watch it if you haven't sword
don't watch that until after you see the
movie if they gonna tell you in the
beginning the spoilers but listen we're
moving on here and we are moving
together as one unit we appreciate
everybody that was in here today and
everybody's gonna be here next week
thank you so much for the likes follows
and and sharing make sure you share it
out to everybody
absolutely a king could've said it best
man you old chap was absolutely
fantastic
aside from a dick throwing people in
jail we will get that straight salute to
the dead today was outstanding man again
please support the realm you know we try
to put out a quality product to you guys
and again salute like I said our guest
Lord mine's Lord mojo and again I want a
king winner three I want to thank him
for a service man I forgot to thank him
for his service
man F was outdated man was out there
still gaming doing what he had to do the
game we appreciate and we appreciate the
global presence of course mods in the
building Poland represent Norwegian
represent UK out there we see in this
it's very humbling much appreciated and
again Lords of gaming dotnet we gonna
have some quality articles this we
please check in man support retweet
those articles that's all I got football
is rolling right now so I gotta get out
of here but if anybody else got anything
else we are out peace